fire cable or satellite provider
and now we're live on book TV with
author and legal analyst Jeffrey Toobin
he joins us on our in-depth program for
the next three hours to talk about his
books and answer your questions mr.
Tobin is the author of many books
including the oath too close to call and
his most recent American heiress
Jeffrey Toobin welcome to c-span to's
in-depth the author of seven books and
Counting that's right I save including
your most recent book American heiress
the wild saga of the kidnapping crimes
and trial of Patty Hearst and I want to
begin where you end the book you wrote
this without her cooperation I did how
was that well you know there were
several things that were different about
this book that than my other books this
is the first book I've written that was
really at the border of journalism in
history all the other books that I wrote
I had sort of covered the underlying
story in real time and then wrote about
it this is something you know I was
alive in the 1970s but I was not you
know I was a kid I would you know it had
followed the follow this stuff so I was
really starting from scratch in terms of
my research and I discovered that there
was a tremendous volume of printed
material in particular a hundred fifty
boxes of material about the Symbionese
Liberation Army and it's trials that
bill Harris one of the survivors had and
I managed to obtain access to that so I
knew I had a great deal of material that
no one had ever seen before but
obviously just to answer your question I
would have liked to have talked to Patty
Hearst she made clear through
intermediaries and then indirectly that
you wanted no part of this but I
realized that I had so much material
from her and about her her own book her
own testimony her FBI interviews
transcripts of interviews that she had
given up to the to the FBI and others I
had her perspective and I got to speak
to many people who knew her during that
period and subsequently so I was able to
report around her in a way that I think
I was able to give a fair impression of
her perspective on the event and this
quote probably further explains why you
wrote the book you say quote the
kidnapping foretold much that what
happened to American society in a
diverse number of fields including
illuminating the future for the media
the culture of celebrity
criminal justice and even sports there
was i I sometimes thought of the Hearst
case when I was writing when I was
writing the book as a trailer for
modernity like a coming attractions for
so many things that we began to see in
big ways in small ways I mean it was the
first of the of the great modern
celebrity criminal events that of course
anticipated the OJ Simpson case the
shootout on May 17th 1974 where six of
the eight SLA kidnappers died was the
first live broadcast of a breaking news
event that that anticipated you know so
much of how we cover news and even
smaller things like participants in a
big news story seeking out book deals
during the events here you had Steven
we'd her former fiance you had Jack
Scott who was one of the people who
sheltered the SLA trying to get a get a
book written you have F lee Bailey her
defense attorney trying to write a book
while he was as as a defense attorney so
many things that became commonplace
started or became visible in the Hearst
and in the Hearst kidnapping saga and of
course Randolph and Katherine Hearst
their pictures were newspapers they were
on television and he made a reference to
the black dress that she often wear her
mother
why well you know what one of the the
the important back stories of the whole
kidnapping and in its aftermath was
Patricia Hearst difficult relationship
with her mother Katherine Hearst I mean
there was nothing particularly or there
is there was and is excuse me let me
just take a sip here by the way Patty
Hearst is still alive very much very
much still alive living in the New York
suburbs she's 62 years old mostly you
know a homemakers socialite she's got
two daughters couple grandchildren and
she raises show dogs
that's what she which she does a lot of
the time but just to answer your
question about the black dress because I
think this is this is important like a
lot of 19 year olds Patti was 19 when
she was kidnapped
she had a contentious relationship with
her mother especially in the 70s where
people used to talk all the time about
the generation gap Katharine Hurst came
from a very conservative Georgia family
and Patty at the time of her kidnapping
was living with her boyfriend what used
to be called living living in sin with
Stephen weed
her fiancee and there was a lot of
contention there and when patty was
kidnapped and there were all these press
conferences that her parents held in
front of their house and in in Hillsboro
patty said and one of the early
communicate you know mom get out of that
black dress you know that's not helping
anyone and and it was an interesting
signal of how she was bringing her
rebellion against her parents into her
life with the SLA that part of the
reason why she joined the SLA was that
she was alienated from her parents not a
big deal in ordinary circumstances a lot
of 19 year old young women are alienated
from their mothers but here under these
extraordinary circumstances it turned
out to be significant and there's a way
to get her release do you write the
following the event was without
precedent in American history no one had
tried on short notice to feed thousands
of people what made the moment even more
extraordinary was that it took place
because of a political kidnapping now
this is a program put in place by Patty
Hearst mom and dad right just just to
back up a little bit when Patty Hearst
was kidnapped initially there was no
ransom demand I mean the there there
were these bizarre communicates from
this group that called itself the
Symbionese Liberation Army but unlike
most kidnappings they didn't say give us
money and we'll give you the person back
and eventually the SLA which was chaotic
and disorganized
sort of on the spur of the moment said
okay well Randy Hirst Patricia's father
he has millions of dollars let's make
him feed the poor that will be our
initial ransom demand and Randy Hearst
remarkably actually set up an entire
organization called people in need run
out of a big warehouse in in in San
Francisco and they did in fact spend
millions of dollars feeding the poor it
didn't go very smoothly in some of the
food distributions there were riots
people were you know the so many people
wanted the food that the people were
injured so you can get out but Randy
Hearst who I think is sort of one of the
few heroes in the story Randy really
wanted to get his daughter back and he
had less money than the SLA thought he
did but he spent millions to set up this
organization which did in fact give out
a lot of food this is the picture of
Katherine Hearst and Steven weed after
the kidnapping he does not come across
as a very strong character no no it's
funny you know one of the things I
learned in doing you know lots of
interviews about this story is that the
only thing that the FBI the SLA the
Hearst family and Patricia herself had
in common was that none of them could
stand steven weed that was the one point
of unanimity you know steven was was a
23 year old I mean that you know this is
not a bad person a bad guy he was a
graduate student in philosophy but he
was kind of haughty and arrogant and and
he thought he sort of knew better than
everyone about how to handle the
situation and he succeeded only in
annoying everybody and the Hearst family
and Patricia
were particularly resentful of the fact
that during the kidnapping itself on the
night of February 4th 1974 after he was
hit by Bill Harris one of the kidnappers
he ran off instead of staying to protect
Patricia we will spend the next three
hours with author and lawyer Jeffrey
Toobin our phone lines are open you can
also join us on facebook at facebook.com
slash book TV set
to tweet at book TV our Twitter is at
book TV and you can also send us an
email book TV at c-span dot-org on
average how long does it take for you to
write a book well I have a very
simple-minded system for writing books
which is related to the fact that you
know I am a staff writer at The New
Yorker and my editor there David Remnick
gives me a limited amount of time off I
can't I don't have the bandwidth the
capacity to both write New Yorker
articles and and continue my work at the
New Yorker but what I do is when I am in
the writing portion of the book after I
have done enough reporting to feel like
I have enough material I write five
pages a day I write 1250 words a day and
that is I find a significant amount but
not an overwhelming amount to write and
it really accumulates
if you keep up at that pace it's 25
pages a week a hundred pages a month and
I find that that gets me to an
appropriate book length in somewhere
around six to eight months that's just
the writing no I view the reporting the
research as equally if not more
important than the writing that is a
little harder to measure how long that
takes that varies as I said in these
other books I've written I was sort of
reporting in real time so it wasn't a
sort of a separate research period but
you know all in at least a year but
probably somewhat more let's talk about
the kidnapping that took place in 1974
you have a picture of the house where it
took place in San Francisco and you know
in Berkeley in Berkeley you also point
out though that how San Francisco has
changed significantly from the 70s to
where it is today it really is
remarkable I mean that this to me was
one of the real revelations in writing
American heiress is that how different
the 1970s were especially in Northern
California from from the way things are
today I mean just give you one statistic
in the in the mid-1970s there were a sow
political bombings a year in the United
States think about what that would be
like today you know most of them didn't
cause injuries or death although some
did but this was just a time of
tremendous political violence and the
epicenter was the Bay Area San Francisco
and and and Berkeley you know the the
there had been the Summer of Love in San
Francisco in 1967 there had been the
Free Speech Movement in Berkeley in 1965
but by the seventies those movements
which began with a good deal of idealism
had curdled into real anger and
resentment and San Francisco in
particular was riven by terrible crime
including you know the the zodiac
killers the zebra killers you know I
think people forget everybody remembers
Dirty Harry
you know Clint Eastwood's famous
detective he was a San Francisco
detective because San Francisco at the
time of those movies was the symbol of
all that was horrible and dangerous in
the United States today of course San
Francisco is you know Silicon Valley and
you know the high tech and prosperity
and high rents then it had a completely
different reputation which was just
interesting to me as someone who you
know was just coming at the story knew
we want you to join in on the
conversation 2:02 is the area code 7 for
889 20 for those of you who live in the
eastern or central time zones and to 0
to 7 4 8 8 201 in the mountain Pacific
time zones we also welcome our listeners
on c-span radio our conversation as we
do the first Sunday of every month here
on c-span 2 with Jeffrey Toobin let me
go back to a 1997 interview on NBC's
Dateline with Patricia Hearst
Patricia how are we to understand them
the so-called missing year of your life
after Mel's Sporting Goods after the
shoot at the SLA members are killed you
could have left at any number of points
well I just think it's not true that I
could have left at any point I couldn't
do anything at any point anymore
I couldn't even think thoughts for
myself anymore because I had been so
programmed that you know the FBI was
looking for the SLA I shouldn't even try
to think about rescue because they would
call in psychics to find me and that's
the kind of thing that I believed so
what led her to basically stay with him
cuz she joined in I mean she was part of
the group her name was Tanya if she
called herself Tanya she took the name
Tanya because Che Guevara's
partner and fellow revolutionary in in
Bolivia was Tanya an East German and
East German went woman uh you know one
of the things I tried to stay away from
in writing American heiress was the
jargon that's associated with the story
brainwashing Stockholm Syndrome all of
which are journalistic terms they're not
scientific terms and try and I try to
look at the facts of the story and what
actually happened and when you see what
Patricia's life was like during that
year between May of 74 and September of
75 when she is when she's arrested you
see these tremendous these repeated
opportunities for her to leave that that
she accounted police officers she went
to hospitals she had poison oak she
needed to get treated and she gave a
fake name she traveled across the
country with Jack Scott and his parents
his elderly parents who basically begged
her to go back to her family and my
simple-minded view and I think it's good
to look at things sometimes in a
simple-minded way is that she didn't go
back because she didn't want to go back
she had joined the SLA like a lot
of young people did in the 70s they
joined in with revolutionary groups that
they later roll their eyes and thought
how in the world could I have been
involved with those crazy people I have
no doubt that she wouldn't do it today
like most of those people wouldn't do it
today but then she did and you're very
descriptive in the conditions that she
was in here's somebody who grew up in
wealth and privilege and she was in an
apartment a house that was pretty
squalid that was dirty she took the name
Tanya she met with who she called her
comrades as they welcomed her into the
SLA so it's a very different lifestyle
to say the least life you know to call
the way they lived a lifestyle almost it
you know it inflates it beyond what it
was they were they were Desperados on
the run and they had no money you know
sometimes people ask you know were they
on drugs the answer is no and the reason
at least in part is they had no money to
buy drugs even if they were inclined in
that direction
they they robbed banks they robbed three
banks for the very simple reason that as
Willie Sutton said that's where the
money was they needed money and they
were living on enormous twenty pound
bags of chicken parts at one point they
ate horse meat
they bought enormous containers of black
of black beans and black-eyed peas you
know the cheapest food they could have
that's the life she was living living
for much of this time and it was very
tough well you have the picture and take
a look at this film from one of the bank
robberies that became one of the iconic
photographs of the mid-1970s
where was she what was she doing and why
did this become synonymous with her with
her situation this video is from the
first bank robbery the most the most
famous one remember she was kidnapped on
February 4th 1974 on March 31st just six
six or so weeks later she issues the
communique that she says she's Tanya two
weeks later on April 15th this robbery
that we're looking at now it's the
Hibernia Bank in the very quiet Sunset
section of San Francisco
they go in as a group and remember just
how weird and and and shocking this was
no bank robbery as scary as it is is
usually committed by one or two people
this was this in you know the basically
all six of the eight actually kidnapped
this Symbian DS Liberation Army members
were involved in some way in this bank
robbery and they had scouted the
location of this bank robbery and
noticed a relatively new innovation
security camera and they stationed
Patricia as you can see right now she
was told to stand where they knew she
would be photographed by the security
cameras as in fact she was because the
SLA believed in guerrilla theater
several of them came from the Indiana
University theater program and they
wanted to show off that their prized
recruit and so that's why they put her
at that part that that part of the bank
so that she would be so so the camera
would take her picture
another book the nine inside the secret
world of the Supreme Court how are they
doing now with eight well you know the
the Supreme Court can clearly function
with eight people it is it is not
designed to to be function with eight
people you know I think most people
don't realize historically you know the
Constitution does not set a number of
justices and until just after the Civil
War the number fluctuated actually in a
number of justices because Congress can
raise or lower the number of justices at
any time but I mean just to state the
obvious there's a reason why there's an
odd number of justices on the court
because tie votes are you know not a
that's not an effective way for the
court to operate this is not ideal but
it is certainly a it doesn't mean the
Supreme Court is not functioning but
it's just indicative of the political
dysfunction that we live with that
vote has taken place on Merrick garland
is the Chief Justice John Roberts the
umpire that he said he wanted to be well
you know Chief Justice Roberts is an
extremely impressive person and he is a
very good symbol and custodian of the
courts public persona he is I think
someone who takes very seriously the
courts how the court is perceived in the
country and I think does his best and
does a very good job to make sure the
court is seen in the best possible light
he is also a serious judicial
conservative he is someone who at like
the other eight justices was appointed
by a president who wanted him to
represent a certain ideological
perspective on the court and Roberts has
done just that he now faces a very
unusual and extraordinary indeed
situation where a Chief Justice may be
in the minority in a great number of
cases going forward if in fact Barack
Obama or if Hillary Clinton wins hit her
appointees represent a majority on that
court and one final question before we
get to calls do you suspect that the
Senate will go back on its pledge not to
have a hearing on Merrick garland if
Hillary Clinton is elected and it
appears as if she'll announce her
success her appointment after she
becomes president in January of next
year no I I think when Mitch McConnell
says that the next president should fill
this seat I think he means the next
president should fill this seat by no
means does that mean if Hillary Clinton
wins she will have an easy glide path to
confirm whoever she appoints but I don't
see any real possibility that this
Senate which is so politically polarized
it includes people like Ted Cruz and Tom
cotton who will not stand for any sort
of vote
on an Obama nominee and can gum up the
works
given the very tight timeframe I just
think the idea that there will be a
lame-duck confirmation seems out of the
question now I think it's possible that
Hillary Clinton my tree nominate Merrick
garland and that that would be an
entirely situation different situation
but in terms of an Obama nomination of
Merrick garland getting a hearing and
vote I don't think it's going to happen
let's go to David joining us from Tulsa
Oklahoma for Jeffrey Toobin go ahead
David thank you for taking my call
first I would very quickly like to thank
c-span you mr. Scully and mr. Swain and
your coverage is a yeah both of the
conventions it was outstanding thank you
money too sorry I don't want to sorry to
interrupt but you know how might as well
add my voice appraised and my question
for mr. douben is is there was there
president as your president for what
Associate Justice Ginsburg Ginsburg did
in speaking out on the political the
presidential campaign in such a way that
became very controversial she army
obviously apologized that I think in
your book nine it's refreshing to get to
know the justices a little bit more and
I applaud you for that and I would like
to know more about the justices so I was
I'd like the fact that she spoke out
well the answer is the answer is in the
modern era there is no precedent for an
explicit endorsement or non endorsement
by a Supreme Court justice in the middle
of a presidential race interestingly
during the 40s and 50s William O Douglas
was considered as a possible vice
presidential candidate for for Harry
Truman and and others so you know III
don't
IIIi think you know people can be too
shocked
Supreme Court justices have political
opinions look they are very smart savvy
people they live in Washington they were
appointed by presidents they are very
aware of and interested in presidential
elections but and and also I think you
know we can have a sort of fake naivete
about the a political nature of the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court is a
deeply ideological body and there is not
you know the idea that they are entirely
separate from politics is I think unduly
naive however I do think there is a good
tradition of justices staying out of
direct electoral politics and that's why
Ruth Ginsburg was criticized across the
ideological spectrum for this statement
even even from people who are ordinarily
fans of hers and yet I would certainly
include myself in that group and and I
think she recognized that she'd made a
mistake I know she recognized she made a
mistake she apologized and moved on and
I don't think we'll hear any more
comments about her moving to New Zealand
if Donald Trump wins the election so not
only questions about whether or not
Barack Obama was born in the US during
the 2008 campaign but then came January
20th 2009 Senator Barack Obama taken the
oath of office from the Chief Justice of
the United States we talked about John
Roberts a moment ago here's how it
unfolded
are you prepared to take the oath
senator I am I Barack Hussein Obama I
solemnly swear I Barack Hussein Obama do
solemnly swear that I will execute the
office of President to the United States
faithfully that I will execute
the off faithfully the president office
of President of the United States
faithfully and will to the best of my
ability and will to the best of my
ability preserve protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States
preserve protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States so
help you God so help me God
congratulations mr. Prentiss
[Applause]
[Applause]
soon as you watch that what a mess watch
the president's body language because he
had memorized the oath of office well
well you know it gosh you know I I mean
just to refresh I'm not everybody knows
this who's watching I wrote a book my
this is the sequel to the nine which was
called the oath and the beginning the
opening chapter is about why the oath
was botched between between the two of
them there and I get you know I watched
it many times when I was writing the
book but I haven't watched it for a
number of years and it's startling again
just to see how badly how badly it was
botched and the real reason it was
botched was a classic bureaucratic snafu
which is that Chief Justice Roberts his
his assistant sent a copy of the oath
with the clauses marked off for how he
was going to divide it up you know
divide up the words sent it to the
inaugural committee but not to Obama's
office that document which I actually
have a copy of was never forwarded to
Obama's transition office so Obama
didn't know how Roberts was going to
divide up the words and if you see what
happens there is that the the Roberts
thinks he's going to say I Barack
Hussein Obama do solemnly swear and
Obama interrupts him after do saw after
his name and then Roberts gets flustered
and the whole thing goes to hell that
but but it's all because neither one of
them knew how the other was going to
break up the word in what's interesting
in the book is you talk about the next
day the first full day of the Obama
White House the number one issue was he
legitimate in taking the oath of office
was he a legitimate president which
really created a White House debate so
talk a bit about that well the there
were newspaper stories about sort of the
oath and David Barron who was a young
assistant
a deputy assistant attorney general I
mean hardly anyone was in their offices
at that point I had a conversation with
Greg Craig who was the White House
Counsel at the time and said you know I
mean remember this is a president who
some people think wasn't even born in
the United States so we have to be sure
of his legitimacy we have to be sure
there are no shadows on on his
legitimacy the so they on the morning of
the 21st have all these sort of not
panicked but sort of serious
conversations about you know what should
we do about that and in short order they
decide you know just to be sure
belt-and-suspenders let's let's redo it
and they call the chief justices
chambers Greg Craig the White House
Counsel calls and says you know we'd
like to do this and Roberts you know
true to his sort of Midwest Midwestern
graciousness says absolutely I'd be
happy to do it
and Roberts that afternoon comes over to
the White House and they and they
reenact the oath just a bizarre
PostScript
when when Obama is re-elected on in 2012
inauguration day falls on a Sunday and
on by tradition the public ceremony is
never on a Sunday so Roberts it came to
the White House and admitted the
administered the oath privately on
Sunday and then publicly and
successfully on on you know in front of
the Capitol so Barack Obama is the only
president except Franklin Roosevelt to
take the office out of office for four
times what was interesting is that there
is no video that moment we had the
picture from the White House of the
Chief Justice giving him the oath of
office January 21st 2009 but the White
House did not allow reporters they
allowed a pool photographer a print
photographer but no video of that
ceremony right Robert Gibbs who was the
incoming White House press secretary at
the time you know this was something
that was happening very much on the fly
he was given short short notice and he
decided in effect the heck with a video
a video pool of this will just have
still photographers but I think in
retrospect it was a it was a mistaken
decision not not to have a video record
of that there were a handful of
witnesses there there was a pool of
reporters who were present and some of
them have you know just pulled their
tape recorders out and and I had a
chance to listen to the audio but there
is no video of the of what happened
there
next is Jim joining us from Caliente
California you're on with Jeffrey Toobin
who's also a writer for The New Yorker
and a contributor to CNN good good
afternoon Jim thank you thank you very
much for having me enough thank you for
this show you do and for c-span in
general which is a wonderful network one
of the great ones didn't Franklin
Roosevelt take the oath in he did it I
believe in one take the first the first
inaugural he memorizes yes yes there you
know what when I was writing the oath
III got into oath minutiae oath history
and you're absolutely right that that
Franklin Roosevelt is the only president
of the modern ear you know we don't have
tape recordings of how it went much
before him but who just recited it
outright without the Chief Justice
telling telling him what to say you know
another another sort of peculiarity of
the oath story is that the last line
that we're so familiar with so help me
God so help me God he is associated with
George Washington
he said George Washington supposedly
said it after being sworn in as as the
first president
but even that is subject to a little bit
of historical debate the the fact that
he supposedly said it wasn't disclosed
until about twenty or thirty years later
and the question arises why did no one
talk about it if that's what he said for
another 20 or 30 years so there is a lot
of sort of mystery about how the oath
evolved the way it did
Jim you still there was that your only
question or did you want to follow up my
I wanted to ask also about the
appointments to the court beginning with
with Bork
where I thought he was unfairly treated
and I think that's where the politicos
ation of the court began and since then
we've had what I would call boring
appointments not because they're not
brilliant lawyers not because they don't
have the background or the skills but we
used to have law professors my my
constitutional law professor at
Northwestern many years ago with
Nathaniel Nathan Center was one of
Brande Isis last law clerks and Brandeis
was not I do not believe with a judge
goldberg and stevens came out of my law
school Northwestern but lately have just
been Harvard and Yale we don't have that
the the the scope and the the diversity
that we I believe we should have on the
court with everybody going to the same
schools getting the same education all
being Supreme Court clerks and so on and
I just like your comments on that well
you know diversity I think you make an
excellent point about diversity and we
usually think about diversity in terms
of race and gender and obviously that is
very important but there are other kinds
of diversity as well think about this
fact the Supreme Court that decided
Brown V Board of Education in 1954 not
one of the justices had been a full time
judge before going on the Supreme Court
Earl Warren was governor of California
William Douglas was head of the
Securities and Exchange Commission Hugo
black was a Senator Robert Jackson had
been the Attorney General I mean these
are people who led big complicated
public lives in the modern era and I
think you're right to pinpoint the Bork
the the Bork nomination is the turning
point is there has been a tendency to
move towards only appeals court judges
when Samuel Alito replaced Sandra Day
O'Connor all
justices were former federal appeals
court judges and I think the the court
really does miss something without
people who had run for elective office
for example Sandra Day O'Connor was the
last justice who would run for office
she had been a state senator in Arizona
I think it's a terrible loss for the
court that they don't have that kind of
diversity of experience but I do think
that I think the caller is right that
the Bork experience led presidents to
pick people with relatively bland public
records that even though people on the
inside might know their actual political
views they are they're seen as safe
choices because they can't be pinned
down with controversial opinion let me
follow up on that Jeffrey Toobin you
write in the book quote temperamentally
Chief Justice Rehnquist never left the
Nixon Justice Department justice
O'Connor the former Arizona State State
Senator that you just pointed out never
stopped being a politician Antonin
Scalia Stephen Breyer remained forever
the law professors that they once were
and John Roberts was a litigator whose
primary responsibility was to figure out
ways to win that's right and and and
that's IIIi think illustrates why
diversity is is is a real value I mean
Sandra Day O'Connor wanted the court to
stay towards the center of American
politics they because that was the kind
of politician and the kind of judge she
turned out to be you know Antonin Scalia
was someone who had very definite views
born in the Academy of what the
Constitution meant and he spent two plus
decades trying trying to push that
agenda I I think you know these justices
are the people they always were I just
wish that the talent pool was different
that it wasn't just appeals court judges
and law professors go back to the book
this is a tweet from one of our viewers
disagreeing with your assessment of
Patricia Hearst saying quote I disagree
with mr. Tuba that Miss Hearst joined
the SLA she was a victim
mr. Tobin does not understand
brainwashing
well you know this this is an argument I
take very seriously and I and also you
know as someone who has covered criminal
laws of as a former prosecutor I am very
aware that you know crime victims are
people who need to be treated fairly and
with dignity and there is no question
that Patty Hearst was a crime victim she
was kidnapped it was a terrible thing
she was put in a car she was put in a
she was put in a car trunk and then and
then put in a closet and and and and she
had no role she had no agency she had no
participation and that there were you
know have been rumors over the years
that she had some role in staging her
own kidnapping that's all total nonsense
she was a pure crime victim however
there there comes a point when people do
change and you look at what happened
from February of 74 to September of 75
and you look at her behavior and the
only conclusion I can draw is not that
she was brainwashed which is a concept
that I think is is is murky at best the
cot that what I believe happened is this
was a restless and vulnerable woman who
was appealed to by people who were
treating her by and large well by March
and April she fell in love with one of
her captors Willie Wolfe I don't think
there's any doubt about that
and then she joined in with him and
spent the next year on the run when
Willie Wolfe was one of the people who
was killed in the big shootout with the
Los Angeles Police Department in May she
meets up then with Steve Solia and as
she acknowledges in her own book she
falls in love with him so you know yes
she was a crime victim and yes crime
victims definitely deserve our sympathy
and respect but in this circumstance my
conclusion was she she joined the SLA
why did how did she get the pardon by
President Carter well she got a
commutation from President Carter
and a part from prudent President
Clinton and I think that's that's
significant just to again bring people
up to date on the story she is tried
after she's arrested for the first of
the three bank robberies she's involved
in again keep in mind this isn't just
one bank robbery she did she did three
including one where a woman was killed
she was tried for the Hibernia bank
robbery which was the first one the one
we saw the surveillance video from on
April 15 1974 in San Francisco she made
the defense that the caller was talking
about on the people were talking about I
was brainwashed I was coerced and the
jury rejected that defense and she was
convicted and sentenced to seven years
in prison following the failure of her
Appeals the Hearst family organized this
tremendous drive for President Carter to
commute her sentence Ronald Reagan a
close friend of the Hearst family joined
in this effort her local congressman Leo
Ryan joined in the this effort and
something happened on the eve of the
decision Carter's decision about whether
to commute her sentence that really
tipped the balance and that was people
who were alive in the 70s may remember
this the Reverend Jim Jones followers
who was also from San Francisco in kam
Guyana committed mass suicide they all
drank the expression a lot of people
hear this expression they don't know
where it came from they drank the
kool-aid they drinks cyanide laced
kool-aid and they committed mass suicide
that created enormous interest in the
United States in the subject of
brainwashing how could you get people to
do something like this and Carter in the
immediate aftermath commuted her
sentence and she only served 22 months
and Congressman Ryan was killed in the
shootout that same time exactly who was
killed in Guyana visiting his
constituents
two decades later Bill Clinton is about
to leave office and Jimmy Carter and
Rosalyn Carter
urge him strongly to pardon Patty Hearst
and on the same day that he issued
pardons for his for his brother Roger
Clinton the his the the pardon for mark
rich the fugitive financier he pardoned
Patty Hearst and you know my view of of
the commutation and the pardons it is
the purest example of how wealth and
privilege helped Patty Hearst
you know our prisons are full of people
who fall in with bad people and make bad
decisions and wind up locked up for a
very long time there are lots of people
like that but our system does not have
much room for forgiveness of those
people but Patty Hearst becomes the only
person the only person in all of
American history to receive a
commutation from one president and a
pardon from another and that to me is a
story about wealth and privilege and the
relationship with her mom post
commutation you know like so many
teenagers who find their parents
intolerable and unfair and annoying she
not only become develops a loving
relationship with her mother as I see it
she'd be there very much becomes her
mother like a lot of us become our
parents let's go to Roger in Decatur
Georgia with Jeffrey Toobin hey thank
you for c-span hey Jeffrey let me say
first that I I find your work to
journalistic that it's not really
thoughtful enough for someone who's not
writing on deadline but I'd like to get
some some of your experiences observers
Supreme Court do you think the justice
that justices have a jurisprudence when
they come to the court is this something
that's sort of created by law professors
if they write about or then the justices
try and follow it is it something that
they're trying just be consistent with
the opinions that they've written and
they sort of find themselves boxed into
a place where they
can't change in other words now I get
your question let but and let me try to
give you a thoughtful answer that you'll
that you'll find the you'll find
satisfactory the the supreme the the
Constitution is a document that does not
interpret itself it is subject to many
many interpretations and the it is a
political document an interpretation of
the political to a political document is
a political act and the reason justices
are picked for the court is that
presidents think they will be able to
extend their own political and
ideological legacy through their
appointments and you know what they do a
pretty good job of it
that's why we see the four Democratic
appointees voting one way and the four
Republican pointees voting the other in
most not all but in most cases you know
when you look at questions like does the
Constitution protect a woman's right to
choose an abortion may a university
consider race and admissions does the
Constitution require that every state
allow gay people to get married the
Constitution doesn't answer those
questions you need an ideological
approach to the Constitution to answer
those questions and there are
differences and they are largely based
on politics and that's why it matters
whether democratic or republican
presidents make appointments send us a
tweet at book TV you can also send us an
email at book TV at c-span org and this
is from Lauren who says whatever
happened to Stephen weed did you
interview him for the book I sure did
well he was a graduate student in
philosophy when he was living with Patty
Hearst and he didn't become a
philosopher he became a real estate
broker in in Silicon Valley and he has
led a very nice life in in largely in
obscurity the way most people do and
he's a nice guy
and he remains somewhat bewildered as
anyone would be bewildered by this
crazy experience but he's you know he
said he's old you know now in his
mid-60s and married kids fine in the
interest of full disclosure we're
obviously interested in this tweet this
is from a viewer saying I've read all
your books signed by him can Geoffrey
comment on the future of video in the
Supreme Court oh man
c-span has a real ax to grind on this
one well I'm with you next to cry I know
don't want to open the process we want
to open it yet no look you know the I
used to say that the reason there were
no cameras in the court in the Supreme
Court could be answered in two words and
those two words were John Stewart
because the justices didn't want to be
made fun of on the daily show now Jon
Stewart has gone from the Today Show but
I think the the concept is the same and
and you know we talk about Pakistan
Combe syndrome in the in the context of
the the Patty Hearst case how about
Stockholm Syndrome in the case of Sonia
Sotomayor and Elena Kagan both of them
during their confirmation hearing said
oh you know I think cameras in the
courtroom would be a great idea now you
ask them it's like oh I don't know I'm
worried about the I'm worried about the
effect on the deliberations I mean to me
the arguments against cameras in the
Supreme Court are terrible arguments
there are no witnesses to be interm
intimidated this is just lawyers arguing
the importance of the subject matter is
unquestioned it's their candy store they
don't want to open themselves up to too
much scrutiny one thing I do think will
happen in the next decade or so is I do
believe the justices will will
eventually allow live streaming of the
audio of Supreme Court arguments because
you know there already are microphones
there they already are if they release
the audio at the end of the week when
they have arguments I think that will be
their concession to the modern world
and I think they will recognize excuse
me correctly that
that takes the heat off them for video
video would be different I mean I in
fairness to the justices you'd have to
you know put in cameras you'd have to
change the lighting and you know I think
they should but it would be a
significant change the live streaming
the audio would offer no change at all
from the 9:00 quote outsiders tend to be
surprised by how rarely Supreme Court
justices speak to each other one on one
under justice Rehnquist the nine spent a
good deal of time together as a group
what's changed you know it hasn't
changed that much and what one other
thing you know John Roberts was a law
clerk to William Rehnquist when
Rehnquist was an associate justice and I
think temperamental II and in terms of
the interpersonal dynamics Roberts has
very much replicated the the Rehnquist
court
Rehnquist served under Chief Justice
burger who was genuinely unpopular among
his colleagues in part because they his
colleagues thought burger tried to have
too much of a heavy hand in the courts
deliberations and Rehnquist said look we
are going to disagree that's inevitable
but we are not going to bother each
other so Rehnquist who didn't have a lot
of patience in general tried to move
things along
and the courts conferences their secret
nine you know when they meet with each
other to discuss the cases basically
they would go around the table and vote
they wouldn't discuss the cases very
much and that is expanded a little bit
under Roberts but it's basically it's a
similar it's a similar scenario
Rehnquist philosophy about the justices
was good fences make good neighbors just
you know we leave each other alone we'll
get along better and it remains mostly
that way I mean they do interact
somewhat but this is really nine
separate law firms and they vote and
they exchange memos but that's mostly it
Nancy you're next from Brooklyn New York
I have two questions one is what is the
derivation of the Symbionese Liberation
Army name and two is I'm mystified that
a person who
you know 70 years old would not be able
to acknowledge that they were a
different person 50 years ago from the
one they are today so I I'm kind of
mystified and puzzled and wonder if you
could comment on that I know you don't
know her motivations but it just seems
bizarre to me as an elderly person
myself Thanks and we should point out
she's in her early early sixties yeah
and and as far as I'm concerned the
early 60s are not elderly because I'm
you know I say it becomes a little more
in the food foreseeable foreseeable
future I don't want to think of that as
elderly so I don't think Patty Hearst is
is elderly but it's a good point
I think people become locked in with
their stories you know people try to
justify their behavior people try to
explain it's a lot easier to say you
were a victim than to say you actually
participated in in some very bad acts
and you know there were some very bad
acts during that Lost year that Patty
Hearst was on the run with the remnants
of the SLA you know to more bank
robberies including one where a woman
named Myrna opsahl was killed there were
bombings she shot up a street in Los
Angeles I mean this was a serious crime
wave bye-bye Patty Hearst and others
which renders her commutation and pardon
all the more incredible to answer your
first question Donald D fries was the
leader of the SLA you know it's funny a
lot of people today think oh well the
SLA that they were like one of those
black revolutionary groups Donald
DeFries was the only african-american in
the SLA and he generally collected
recruits about him that were mostly
middle class kids Berkeley students
Berkeley dropouts into some students who
had migrated from Indiana and he came up
with the word Symbian EES which is sort
of a corruption of symbiosis he thought
you know people working together in in
symbiosis he
he made up the words than viennese you
know he called himself some people may
remember general Field Marshal Singh Q
which was an illustration of these sort
of insert absurd inflated concepts that
they had about their their own
importance and you know and and that's
why he called them an army and and and
liberators but you know as I point out
in American heiress Symbian Symbian E's
is not a word they didn't liberate
anything or anyone
and they certainly were no army because
there were about a dozen of them tops
but that's the derivation of the of the
name and you have a relatively recent
photograph of Patty Hearst I do in New
York City yeah and and you know she is
now best known for raising show dogs she
raises shih tzus and she had a victory
with a shih tzu named rocket at the
Westminster Kennel Club in in in one of
the divisions so you know one of the
amazing things about Patty Hearst story
is that for all the Crump the the the
tumult and the crisis of the these
events and going to prison she has led
the life for which she was destined she
is sort of a wealthy homemaker socialite
and just shows we are who we are
Richard Ventura California you are next
thank you I love book TV and as a former
prosecutor I'm reading your book on the
Hearst case with great interest do you
notice that you noted in the book that
Patty Hearst was living at 2603
benvenuto in Berkeley which was the
scene of the kidnapping correct in 1970
I lived at 2606 Benzinger Avenue which
was a two story apartment building
across the street indeed and that's
where you said in the book that they
some of the students witnessed part of
the thing and were fired upon by two of
the kidnapped well actually actually not
the the they were the
the this the students who were studying
for the biochemistry exam they were not
across the street they were next door
oh and and they were standing on the
porch I mean one of the incredible
things when you think about the the the
kidnapping and the whole saga of the SLA
is and and Donald DeFries and Nancy Ling
Perry opened up and fired on these kids
who were who were you know who came out
onto the porch to see what was going on
it's a miracle that they didn't kill
more people considering how many rounds
of ammunition they fired both at the
kidnapping at the bank robbery at the at
the shootout in Los Angeles one thin and
Patty Hearst herself and Mel
sporting-goods we can only be grateful
that the SLA were just horrible horrible
shots
Richard is still there up sorry I
interrupt you noted in the book how
radical the area was at the time but you
failed to mention another famous female
resident of Bend renew a venir was that
Rawdon Klimt Robin Rodham Clinton lived
on benzene who have anew in the summer
of 1971 she came all the way across the
country from Yale to work for a radical
law firm which represented many of the
revolutionaries of the time like the
Black Panthers yeah it's nice to me I'm
killin ya well it's a true story it's
you can look it up on the internet and
so on I hope you'll people not only to
read your book but Brian burrows book
days of Rage which is in your
bibliography it's really an excellent
book on the era
can I just second that motion
enthusiastically Brian burrows book days
of Rage is about all or many of the
radical movements of the 1970s it mostly
focuses on the Weather Underground but
it also talks about the Puerto Rican FAL
and there is some stuff about this in
Viennese Liberation Army it's a terrific
book and I'm delighted that you
mentioned it and I'm happy to endorse
your recommendation we have seven books
to go through so the one
too close to call and first I want to
read a quote from the book in reference
to the Supreme Court you say well it's
just you should say it's about the
recount in two thousand right right and
you say in all the Supreme Court's
performance in the election cases Bush v
Gore vindicated once more the famous
observation offered by Justice Robert
Jackson back in 1953 he said quote we
are not final because we are infallible
but we are infallible only because we
are final so let me ask you about that
point and also what Al Gore did not do
that might have changed history
oh boy okay well you know of all my
books too close to call my favorite
stepchild because you know the two
closer to through it well I lived
through it I was in Florida for the
whole 36 days except I came up to
Washington for both of the Supreme Court
arguments but that book came out in
October of 2001
now you remember there was a pretty big
news event in September of 2001 so you
know it came out in the immediate
aftermath of 9/11 and people did not
want to hear about Bush v Gore after
9/11 especially a few weeks afterwards
so that was a tough sell and that book
was not I'm pleased to say unlike the
others not not not a commercial success
and and I guess I I have a special
fondness for it for just for just that
reason I have a lot of respect for the
Supreme Court the liberals the
conservatives a lot alike I disagree
with many decisions but I certainly
understand why they came out the way
they did Bush v Gore I think is a very
dark moment in the history of the
Supreme Court I think it is a bad and
nearly indefensible decision it was it
was badly reasoned it was badly written
it was inappropriately
they took they took the case
inappropriately to start with so III
have no you know III I really you know I
still have a very critical view
of that decision but that Robert Jackson
quote which I love basically says though
look we have to stop somewhere somebody
has to have the last word in American
political and legal life and we've
decided to have the Supreme Court do it
for better or worse and that's why our
election ended the way it did in 2000
but that doesn't mean we have to be
happy about and you had really four very
different people who were central to
this first of all george w bush and his
approach al gore the sitting vice
president Warren Christopher the former
Secretary of State in the Clinton
administration and Jim Baker who was a
longtime friend confident and Secretary
of State in the George Herbert Walker
Bush administration and those two played
a central role in the 36 days but they
had a different approach they did and
you know Al Gore chose Warren
Christopher who was this very
distinguished former diplomat because he
thought that this dispute over the very
close outcome in Florida was going to be
handled in a sort of high-minded way and
that in that people would reason
together and figure out a way to come to
a just and fair resolution Jim Baker
knew from the day George W Bush called
him that this was going to be a knife
fight and he knew that this was going to
be something that required all of his
resources legal political media and he
approached it that way and the the
difference in approach and skill level
and enthusiasm between the Democrats and
the Republicans in Florida was one of
the key factors in why the decision came
out the way it did I don't know if Al
Gore had picked different personnel
there might have been a different
outcome and there were heroic efforts on
the part of the Democrats you know Ron
Klain who was through the the the the
young leader of the
mccr attic forces did enormous labor
under very difficult circumstances and
almost still won but the amount of
effort and resources was tremendously
out of balance and that was the result
of the different approaches that the two
sides took and you quote Marty Baron the
former executive editor the Miami Herald
let me share with you this is from a Q&A
interview with Brian lamb it runs about
90 seconds remind us what the Miami
Herald concluded about the Florida
election sure well I'll tell you what we
did first of all is after the US Supreme
Court decided that there would be no
full-scale recount of the vote in
Florida we decided that we should
determine for history's sake what were
the real results and so we did our own
recount we went to every one of the 67
counties in Florida and obtained all the
ballots and we were able to do that
under the really expansive public
records law of Florida which is really
wonderful and so we we obtained all the
ballots we went with a an accounting
firm BDO Seidman at the time and they
did their account and we did our counts
as journalists and we went through every
single ballot and we had the Supervisor
of Elections actually hold up the ballot
and we recorded whether that how that
ballot was voted and whether that ballot
could in fact be counted because in some
instances the ballots were marked in a
way that couldn't possibly be counted
and there were as you may recall there
were different standards so the question
is how do you judge the so-called
hanging chads so a if you had ballots
that were punctured in some way if the
little piece of paper was sort of
hanging on did you count that or did you
not count that and so we looked at the
the vote under various standards and we
determined that George Bush actually won
that election in Florida if I can just
add one more point certainly the Miami
Herald did their own recount later the
National Opinion Research Research
Center at the University of Chicago did
a different even more comprehensive
recount sponsored by a consortium of
of news media organizations including
the New York Times in the in the
Washington Post that reached a somewhat
different conclusion that that said if
the whole state had been recounted gore
would have won now if only the four
counties gore sought to have recounted
Bush would have won and that was a
tactical mistake by Al Gore it was it
was certainly a tactical mistake to call
for only a four a four counties of
recount but but I think the broader
issue is this what we know for sure is
that the Supreme Court's decision in
Bush v Gore ended the recounts there was
no more recount after December of
nineteen you know a no more official
recount of just and and I remember being
in Tallahassee where the recount was
ongoing when the people's primitive cell
phones and cell phones were pretty
primitive in those days started ringing
and people said the Supreme Court has
issued to stay stop counting the ballots
and they did they were they stopped
counting write it right in the middle
what the Miami Herald recount tells us
what the the the broader media recount
tells us is that we will never know we
will never know who won the election who
would have been designated the winner of
the election if the Rican had been
allowed to proceed there are a lot of
people who say well it doesn't matter
because Bush would have won anyway based
on what Marty Baron said there but
respectfully that is not the last word
the last word which I believe with all
my heart is that we cannot know who
would have won because recounts you
can't recreate them they can only happen
in real time and we just don't know who
wouldn't want an email from one of our
viewers where did Jeffrey Toobin go to
college what did he study into that time
in college significantly affect your
future i went to harvard college I
majored in American history and
literature
I wrote my senior thesis about Samuel
Adams and
I'm I just want to say since we're on
television now that if someone wants to
make a musical about Samuel Adams I'm
happy to help
I'm really ready to help Ron chernow is
taking them yeah yeah no I you know I I
in fairness I think Hamilton's life was
a little better it is a little more
suited for a musical did that have an
impact yeah I mean I loved going to
college I spent most of my time in
college at the student newspaper the
Harvard Crimson
I mean that you know that that was
really much more my major than my
academic interests I mean I had liked my
classes and I did well and I was happy
to I was happy to study early in
American history but that was when I
really caught the journalism bug even
though I did go from there to law school
and I but but I still you know I still
have a great fondness for history and
early American history and in writing
American heiress was really kind of a
return to those college roots just in in
one very specific way you know my last
two books had been about the Supreme
Court and I you know the Supreme the
Supreme Court virtually everything about
it now is on PDFs or JPEGs or I mean
it's very easy to manipulate the
research material studying this event
from the 1970s where I had received
these hundred 50 boxes of paper I I it
was really startling and frankly quite
difficult for me to deal with actual
paper again in a research context and I
I'm what I'm very anxious to have these
150 boxes out of my life again
which is about the way send us an email
book TV at c-span org and other viewer
saying what do you like to do in your
free time and what was the favorite your
favorite book to write ah what do I like
to do with my free time you know IIIi
have I love like interesting story
and I love to cover and go places in and
you know be and on you I have a story
coming out in The New Yorker which
required spending a lot of time in
Alabama which I just love because it's
very far from my home in New York so I
like interesting things in the world my
own life is not terribly interesting or
complicated I'm very you know I'm sort
of a homebody I like to play golf with
my wife I like to work out in the gym I
like to read books I mean there is
nothing especially interesting or
colorful about what I do in in my day to
day life but I like to be out in the
world and see the colorful and
interesting things that other people do
that's going to Gary joining us from
Miami Florida go ahead please Gary yeah
hi and I'd like to ask mr. Tobin
something about our current president
I'm a former resident of Hyde Park in
Chicago and I was very familiar with
Reverend Wright in that church and my
question is is the president attended
that church for more than 20 years he
says in his book that Reverend Wright
was his mentor he married Helmut Michele
he blessed his long he baptized his
children and he knew that Reverend
Wright previously had been a plaque
Muslim and he had a company louis
farrakhan to libya so what was your
question our feet well my question is
does jeffrey toobin believe that the
President did not know any of this
or does he come to the conclusion as
many of us do get the president was
either a lying or he isn't as smart as
he is claimed to be well I you know boy
it's like it's 2008 all over yeah I you
know the this was an issue that was
exhaustively examined in the 2008
you know Barack Obama was a parishioner
of Reverend Wright's Church I don't
think that means that the the president
endorsed everything that Jeremiah Wright
ever said I don't think it means that he
knew everything that Jeremiah Wright
ever said you know Barack Obama has been
president for seven and a half years now
and I think there's a lot of basis on
which to judge whether he's been a good
president or not based on what he did as
president what he did or did not think
about Jeremiah Wright at this late date
just seems to me uh turley irrelevant
and I say that respectfully the run of
his life the people versus OJ Simpson
the book that came back into my life
dramatically over the past year and a
half yes as he sits in a Nevada Jail
what do you think is going through his
mind right now boy I got a raw deal boy
people are unfair to me boy I would like
to tell you about all the unfairness
ha's you know one of the things about OJ
is that he is a compulsive talker and he
undoubtedly has a great deal to say
about what's gone on in his life those
recently and in the in the more distant
past you know a lot of people sometimes
have asked me over the years do you know
do you think oh jake has admitted to
himself
that he killed Ron Goldman and his
ex-wife Nicole Brown Simpson and and let
me just lay my cards on the table I
certainly do believe that he did I think
he doesn't really focus on that question
in his thoughts I think he feels like
the the legal system has been unfair to
him and I think like a lot of people who
have been involved in the criminal
justice system they focus on what they
think are the unfairness of the system
and not the underlying conduct that got
him into trouble in the first place and
that's sort of how I think Oh Jay thinks
about as
right now and what are the underlying
questions for those who follow the the
case he had everything going for him he
had celebrity he had a ex-wife who was
beautiful he had two children a terrific
home by all accounts a pretty successful
career both as a football player
commentator actor and celebrity so why
why did he kill them because domestic
violence is a real thing
people you know the the the it's easy to
make complicated arguments about the OJ
Simpson case and in many respects it was
a complicated story but why Oh Jay
killed Nicole because husbands killed
their wives because intimate partners
kill each other because men kill women
and that's what happened here it's
really not that complicated oh look
there I am we're gonna show this is a
you're looking the preview monitor okay
now that's okay
this is from CNN coverage laverda yes
and you were right in the courtroom I I
sure was and there there is Ron
Goldman's father and in front of me
there is there I am with no gray hair at
all 32 years old looking pretty young
and even then I knew that it was an
amazing thing to be in the courtroom at
that moment I knew that this was like
being in the Sapru to film this was a
piece of history that was unfolding and
I didn't even know at that red-hot
moment when the verdict was being
announced about the racially polarized
reactions that we would soon see which
sort of vaulted the story even more into
the public consciousness which is my
next quote from the book you say racism
in law enforcement has persisted through
many decades in American life and black
citizens and thus black jurors have
stored too many insults for too long the
police in general and the LAPD in
particular reap what they sow that's
right and and you know I I wrote this
book in the immediate aftermath of the
OJ Simpson case and 20 years later Brad
Simpson and Nina Jacobson producers came
to me
and said we want to make a miniseries
based on it for the FX network and the
end with Ryan Murphy they made this
magnificent series that was broadcast
earlier this year and you know it just
shows how a great story is timely
forever because the the the miniseries
came out in the immediate aftermath of
Ferguson and Eric Garner's death in New
York and all these incidents that gave
rise to the black lives matter movement
and this story especially the way I
wrote it in the way it was portrayed in
the FX series was about race in America
and about how jurors especially saw
African American jurors saw the
relationship between the African the Los
Angeles Police Department and
african-americans and it turned out in
my view that OJ Simpson desert who
became the utterly undeserving
beneficiary of that poisonous history
but you know this year which had so much
attention on the OJ Simpson case it just
showed how timely that story was because
the relationship between
african-americans and the police remains
a story at the center of American life
yes or no did a verdict surprise you yes
yes it did I mean I I as as my wife and
others have have reminded me many times
you know if you recall what happened the
jury announced that they had reached a
verdict on the previous day and then we
had to wait until 11:00 in the morning
the next day so I was on television you
know all through that be over night so
what do you think is gonna happen and I
predicted that OJ would be convicted and
given how brief the the jury
deliberations were and the fact and I
freely admit this that having sat in the
courtroom throughout the trial I was
utterly convinced of his guilt and I
thought the jury would see it the same
way and I am you know very much ready to
say I was completely wrong Nancy joining
us from Redondo Beach California
you are next good afternoon welcome to
book TV thank you thank you Steve thank
you tubing and thank you man
c-span oh thank you mr. tubing our
timing was almost perfect mr. tube and
regarding the Supreme Court and Bush the
or have you read the Vincent Bugliosi
book The Betrayal of America about that
decision in 2000 it was based on a novel
by none dare call it treason that was in
the nation I believe and it's so what
are your thoughts on that I read that
book like I was a scholar and he
basically said that there was it was
almost treasonous and I would just love
love love to hear your comments on that
I'll hang up and thank you so much well
I I am an admirer of the late Vince
Julio see he was a he was as many people
may remember one of the prosecutors in
the Charles Manson case and his book
helter skelter about the the Manson case
is as far as I'm concerned one of the
great true crime books ever written
Vince was very critical of the decision
in Bush v gore I was very critical of
the decision of Bush v gore I think
Vince's criticism as much as I disagree
with the the decision was a little over
the top frankly I mean to talk about
treason to talk about you know the sort
of apocalyptic sense of how bad it was
and you know I say nothing I say none of
this in order to defend the decision in
Bush v gore but III found that book
somewhat overstated in its criticism
quote Al Gore had seen his recount as a
logic puzzle to be solved after
judicious reflection but while the vice
president and his aides were hunched
over there are calculators the
Republicans were breaking barstools over
their heads yeah you know I as I said I
spent the whole summer the whole 36 days
it wasn't the summer it was November
December of 2000 in Florida in
Tallahassee and one of the things that
you couldn't help but notice was that
the only protesters in the streets were
Republican
and they were out in front of the vice
presidential mansion here in Washington
wearing some ties that start getting
getting saying get it you know get out
get out of Cheney's house get out of
Cheney's house you know the the gore
didn't want any protesters on the street
he wanted this to be an orderly a
political process and I think one of the
main differences between the the two
parties especially between Jim Baker the
Republican leader and Warren Christopher
was that Baker understood that this was
a bar fight as well as a legal fight and
that that was one factor in the outcome
William you're next from Asajj beats
Missouri yes hello I'm your c-span
cartoonist of yesteryear you may
remember corner during that deep
thoughtful years I'm just so tickled to
see you and Jeffrey both and film every
cspan is wonderful c-span is a safety
valve for our system of government in
trying times I think right now okay and
thanks for your work on the Tocqueville
series which by the way is lives forever
on our website at c-span work so we
appreciate that William mr. lamb I trust
is all right and Susan and and
everything yep that is wonderful you
guys are doing and Jeffrey I got to say
it sounds to me like I have got to get I
have your other books either by library
or my wife insists on buying books
nowadays and so probably we've
contributed to you I won't apologize I
just wanted to mention it but I love the
way you write I love the fact that you
write from New Yorker and books I do
have a couple of comments and first of
all I think I have to get your very
first book because it sounds like when I
was teaching criminal justice instead of
practicing law before I started
cartooning online edge D when I did that
what Anthony Lewis's book about about
the Gideon case Gideon
you know what well he was one he was one
of my favorite now I think I've got to
get your book as kind of it must be kind
of the obverse of that case talking
about patty earth and her brushes with
the law so I think I think that's I
think that's going to be very
fascinating I do have a question for you
I think Geoffrey you might be interested
and I appreciate particularly as a
former teacher Chris constitutional law
what you said and I think it was the
nine the book than my the explanations
of the major cases every citizen of the
United States I'll read that book I
swear it's just can you imagine can you
imagine the sale every citizen rather
that would be great hey William thank
you very much for the call all right I
just want to say Jeffrey that if you can
come up with an idea about how many more
people we can put on the Supreme Court
just like Roosevelt tried maybe we'll
get some better decision you know
Roosevelt tried to pack the court with
more than nine now we can't even get to
nine so III think we shouldn't worry
about adding adding to nine let's just
get to nine that that would be a first
that would be a first step one of your
early books opening arguments quote what
Oliver North did deserved imprisonment
North flautas the ideas the values that
you learned at your mother's knee he
lied he cheated and stole one count of
each in fact crimes yeah you know III
I'm pleased to hear you ants ask that
question as if people know who Oliver
North is IIIi I'm the dark Fox
well he's our boss right you know III
but but you know I I feel obligated in
answering that question to explain a
little of the background because I think
the iran-contra scandal is not
necessarily at the top of people's minds
at the moment Oliver North was a
lieutenant colonel in the Marine Corps
who was assigned to the Reagan White
House and he managed
the assistants of his superiors Robert
McFarlane and John Poindexter to provide
assistance to the Contras who were
fighting the the left left-wing
government in Nicaragua was still part
of the Cold War and he managed also to
sell missiles to Iran in order to try to
free hostages and he used some of the
money that he got from Iran to fund the
Contras which Congress had prohibited it
should just point out it's one of the
headlines this week with the freeing of
the hostages and the four hundred
million dollars today that's right you
know it's remarkable how Iran in
particular out of all the countries in
the world manages to confuse and
basically mess up the American
government there is a uniquely bad
relationship between Iran and the United
States that seems to recur in in decade
in decade after decade
anyway north there was an independent
council appointed an outside prosecutor
his name was Lawrence Walsh I was the
junior member of the team that
prosecuted Oliver North for lying to
Congress for for taking a security fence
inappropriately and he was convicted but
but then the the Court of Appeals
overturned his conviction and he has
been out and about ever since he's now a
military analyst on Fox I wrote a piece
about him for The New Yorker quite a few
years ago and I'm pleased to think that
anyone remembers the whole saga at all
we have time for one more call before
short break linda is joining us from
Minneapolis please good afternoon I have
a kind of a not a very significant
question about the Patty Hearst book in
the present mr. Tobin you you mentioned
that she's a homemaker you know I think
she lives in Greenwich and she sort of
you know living a life that she was born
to but didn't he marry
her bodyguard or or her chauffeur isn't
that and and if so what is she still
married this is not a trivial question
at all it is something I explore in the
book she did marry her bodyguard right
after she was released from prison on
bail they her lawyers had to hire
bodyguards for her and they hired a
off-duty San Francisco police officer
named Bernard Shaw the two of them fell
in love and and they married in the late
70s and they moved to the East Coast as
you suggest not to Greenwich and I think
it's fair not to disclose where she
lives she's understandably concerned
about her security but she and Bernie
Shaw had a very long and happy marriage
and they had two daughters
unfortunately Bernie died of cancer in
2013 and and Patty Hearst is now a widow
perhaps not surprisingly Bernie Shaw
became the head of security at the
Hearst Corporation and many of my
friends who work at Hearst magazines
like Esquire or cosmopolitan they all
say oh I knew birdie he took my employee
photo ID and that's the there's a whole
generation of journalists that have
pleasant memories of Bernie Shaw taking
their employee ID photographs at the
Hearst Corporation we are at the midway
point of our three-hour conversation a
lot more to talk about but what's your
next project you know I don't know and
when I write a book uh I find the effort
so all-encompassing that frankly the
last thing I want to think about right
now is what my next book will be about I
I do know happily that I will write more
books but they tend to emerge
organically from my work for The New
Yorker and I don't know exactly I don't
know at all what it will be about much
more with the Jeffrey Toobin here on
c-span twos in depth as we continue our
conversation and more of your calls your
emails in your tweets here on book TV
[Music]
[Music]
here's a look at some books that are
being published this week senior fellow
at the New America Foundation and law
professor at Georgetown University Rosa
Brooks looks at the history of warfare
in the book how everything became war
and the military became everything
inpatient hm journalist Luke Dietrich
looks at the scientific study of memory
and through the lens of his
grandfather's work as a brain surgeon
Elizabeth Greenwood talks about the
death fraud industry and reasons why
some people faked their own deaths in
the book playing dead in way of the
Reaper former Army sniper Nicholas
Irving relates some of his most
dangerous missions in Iraq and
Afghanistan and University of London
researcher Susan Williams recalls
American efforts during World War two to
covertly secure high quality uranium ore
in spies in the Congo look for these
titles in bookstores this coming week
and watch for many of the authors in the
near future on book TV here on c-span to
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
here's a preview of some of the books
being published this fall coming up in
September Fox News host Bill O'Reilly
along with Martin Dugard are releasing
another volume in there killing series
this time looking at war with Japan
during World War two
Candace Maillard looks at the exploits
of a young Winston Churchill during the
second Boer War New York Times columnist
Maureen Dowd shares her thoughts on the
2016 presidential election in the year
of voting dangerously Eagle Forum
founder Phyllis Schlafly along with Edie
Martin and Brett Dekker make a
conservative argument for supporting
Donald Trump and two-time Pulitzer Prize
winning historian Alan Taylor examines
the Revolutionary War and it's aftermath
in American revolutions some books being
published in October Supreme Court
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg releases her
memoir my own words Washington Post
contributing columnist Sebastian Mallaby
profiles former Federal Reserve Chairman
Alan Greenspan also coming up in October
let me tell you about Jasper the latest
from Dana Perino former White House
press secretary and co-host of Fox
News's the five Guardian editor-at-large
Gary Young reports on gun violence in
another day in the death of America and
historian HW brands gives an account of
the rivalry between President Harry
Truman and General Douglas MacArthur
being released in November senator
Bernie Sanders recalls his campaign for
the Democratic Party presidential
nomination in our revolution Fox News
host megyn kelly looks back on her life
and career as a journalist in settle for
more New York Times columnist Thomas
Friedman looks at the speed with which
the world is changing and thank you for
being late John Edgar Weidman African
Studies and literary arts professor at
Brown University profiles Lewis Till
father of civil rights era martyr Emmett
Till and former US special envoy for
Middle East peace
George Mitchell outlines his
recommendations for peace in that region
look for these titles in bookstores in
the coming weeks and months and watch
for the author's on book TV author
columnist lawyer CNN contributor Jeffrey
Toobin the book a vast conspiracy the
real story of the sex scandal that
nearly brought down a president you say
the following when President Clinton was
caught in the most cliched of dilemmas a
menopausal man having an affair with a
young woman from the office he reacted
not with candor and grace but rather
with the dishonesty and self-pity that
are among the touchstones of his career
and his character really did I write
that that's a little that is startling
to me I mean III III look you know Bill
Clinton just state the obvious
should not have been involved with
Monica Lewinsky but I thought that the
hero of the story to the extent there
was one was the American people which
who thought not in not everyone but it's
like oh yeah we get this it's like this
guy had an affair with a woman at the
office but we don't fire people in this
country especially from the presidency
for doing that and I thought the
maturity and the good humor of most
Americans was really a contrast to the
way most politicians and much of the
news media viewed viewed the story I
mean this was a banal story about you
know very ordinary human flaws that was
inflated into this ridiculous
constitutional crisis it was just gonna
jump in because when he said he rose
among the players the key players you
say there were no heroes it was not a
great moment for Americans in public
life and needless to say you know I do
not defend Bill Clinton for his
underlying conduct I don't defend him
for his lying about it which he which he
clearly did but when you look at his
opponents you know the star
investigators who just spent year after
year pursuing him on
nonsense and you know and finally
fastened on to this and not only wasted
an enormous amount of time on it but
also botched the investigation by not
giving her immunity at the beginning and
just getting this thing over with they
you know Bill Clinton was very fortunate
in his adversaries in this ridiculous
drama this is the the cover of the book
wagging the finger what's up with the
tie and Monica Lewinsky that was a you
spent a couple of pages I spent a couple
of pages you know went over when I was
coming here I was thinking is he gonna
ask me stuff that I don't remember
because I wrote this this stuff a long
time ago but I do remember the tie the
but it's one of the gifts that Monica
Lewinsky gave Bill Clinton during their
relationship was a beautiful zinnia tie
and he wore that tie during his his
grand jury testimony which was
ultimately televised and there were
those who thought that this was a symbol
a sign a signal to Monica Lewinsky that
I'm still thinking of you and you know
hold tight to your story defending me
you know that strikes me is a little
far-fetched I devoted an unseemly amount
of time to trying to locate a copy of
the tie and and I had a lot of dealings
with the people from zania one thing I
didn't know is that zinnia rotates their
ties and once they move on they just
sort of move on and they don't have any
so a a great souvenir of covering that
story
I couldn't get because I couldn't get it
I couldn't get one of the ties from the
book a vast conspiracy in the first term
when Hillary Clinton had formal
political responsibilities with regard
to health care she quickly became one of
the least popular first lady's in memory
her defense of her husband during the
Lewinsky scandal however drove her to
great heights of popularity she and her
husband try to capitalize on the good
feelings toward her
yeah yeah that's Akashi you know it it
seems like a long time ago doesn't it
cuz Hillary you know what what our sense
of who hillary clinton is has gone
through quite a quite a number of
iterations but i mean it's just a
demonstration of how long she has been a
major public figure in this country i
mean she became the first lady in 1993
which is 23 years ago and you know she
was the focus of public attention as the
leader of the healthcare case but but i
think you know this was an example of
how the Clintons were fortunate and
their adversaries i mean basically what
happened here you know as i said is that
bill clinton had a relationship in a pro
very inappropriate relationship with
this woman and and then lied about it
but it was essentially a private matter
between him and his family and his wife
and the fact that his opponents tried to
turn it into a constitutional crisis and
she managed to deal with him on a
personal private level I think generated
a lot of sympathy for her I you know
it's just trying to think about the the
patterns of Hillary Clinton's career is
that you know she tends to be least
popular when she is involved in partisan
controversy that was true in health care
and it's true now when she's running for
president you know her her her you know
though she's likely to win she's
certainly not as popular as she was when
she was Secretary of State which was a
largely a political position I think she
is likely to be more popular as a
president if she becomes president than
she is as a candidate she is not a great
candidate she is not a great campaigner
but she's actually it seems pretty good
at being in office she was a very
popular senator in New York she was a
popular Secretary of State so IIIi think
that that is one of the patterns that
has recurred in her life this is an
email from Don who says how do you
structure and organize your
research especially the interviews that
you conduct how you able to handle your
New Yorker obligations and do you have
research assistants you know wow those
are theirs just to answer the last
question I have never been able to hire
research assistants in the sense that
people who go out and do legwork for me
go out and do interviews for me I I I
don't begrudge the writers who do but I
just that's too much a part to me of of
the research itself
I could never sort of hand you know send
that that work out to others you know I
have had people who have helped me with
discreet topics and I'm very pleased to
say that my neighbor in Sherman
Connecticut
Annie Swanson was someone I hired to
create an index for the hundred fifty
boxes of material I got which was
indispensable to trying to you know
figure out how to use all this and so
that's the kind of thing that I've had a
research assistant for sort of discreet
topics a discreet assignments like
creating an index of those boxes as for
how I structure my work to me the
reporting is always the most important
part is you know going out and talking
to people going out and interviewing
people getting the documents reading the
the you know primary source material
that came out at the time once I start
writing as I mentioned to you earlier I
am very fastidious about my five pages a
day quota I I have to get that done
every day because that's how I can
complete a book in a reasonable amount
of time while I'm writing I'm still
reporting and one of the things you
learn at least in my experience when you
are when you do sit down to write is you
learn about the holes in your in your
research so one reason why I write 1,250
words is that it leaves me time every
day to continue my reporting calling
people on the phone
looking up documents so you know I never
stop reporting till you know till the
the book is done it's going to Benjamin
joining us from Florence Massachusetts
you are next
good afternoon and the East Coast you
mentioned earlier your interest in
American history and recently the
subject of Ruth Bader Ginsburg
involvement and political discourse has
come up and it strikes me it's
significant that that in the study of
American history you should well know
that John Jay the first Supreme Court
Chief Justice was in fact twice a
candidate for the governorship of New
York and Charles avenues ran for the
Republican nomination for the presidency
from the Supreme Court that is he got
the nomination then resigned when he got
it and subsequently was appointed Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court and that
William Douglas in fact tried to get the
Democratic nomination for Vice President
in the 1940s so there's a really very
long and consistent history of justices
involvement and political activities and
for Ruth Bader Ginsburg to make a few
comments about the political campaign
strikes me as small potatoes compared to
the history of such involvement well
yeah I know the issue has been raised
but I haven't seen those people who
criticize Ginsburg acknowledged the
historical record and take that into
account in setting her statements in
historical context well IIIi think I
mean as a factual matter you were
clearly correct about John Jay about
Charles Evans used about William Douglas
I actually mentioned Douglass earlier
when this came up times have changed
I mean the the the place of the Supreme
Court in modern life is as the justices
all acknowledged when they are nominated
when they are confirmed they they try to
be more cut off from day-to-day
political events I don't bring
any great naivete to this whole subject
I recognize that Supreme Court decisions
are often deeply political in in their
nature but there is a tradition that is
of many decades standing and and it's
really decades now that justices should
try to stay out of the day-to-day
electoral politics of the country I
think that's an appropriate line to draw
I think Ruth Ginsburg crossed over that
line I think she recognized she
recognized it that's why she apologized
that's why she's not doing it again
you know I agree that this isn't World
War three it's not an impeachment level
crisis but it wasn't some inappropriate
comments that she made and I think she
appropriately apologized for this is
from Jim and I've had three emails on
this so I'm not quite sure what they're
talking about maybe you can elaborate in
FDR's first inauguration there is so
much movement behind him that it looks
like he took the oath of office from a
subway stop please comment beats me when
I when I was writing the oath and
writing that chapter about the history
of the oath I went on YouTube and and
you can see most of the the presidential
oath in the Euro where there is video
I don't remember people walking around
during the Roosevelt one I mean I do
remember that he he recites the oath
from memory without any help from the
chief justice but it's also worth
remembering that you know a lot of what
goes on now is choreographed for
television and that includes
presidential inaugurations which are in
meticulous detail choreographed in 1933
when Franklin Roosevelt took the oath
for the first time there wasn't that
kind of image management you know
newsreels even were in a rather
primitive form so the fact that people
were not aware that they were on camera
perhaps isn't as surprising as all that
Karen is next from Chester Pennsylvania
welcome to c-span two's book TV thank
you
a mr. Tobin I love your work thank you
did you graduate from overbook no but my
dad did my dad was a proud graduate of
Overbrook high school in Philadelphia
where which he would never fail in the
next sentence to say you know will
Chamberlain also graduated from
Overbrook high school so my dad was my
dad was a proud Philadelphia yeah my
husband did too I just want to make a
couple of statements and end with a
question if you could tell me whether my
statements are correct I think your
question about Iran and the relationship
with the USA comes down to two words
comet Roosevelt
anyway next point is I don't understand
why I'm not confused about the Supreme
Court because what I was taught in
civics was that they're neutrals are not
political blah blah blah there's not a
person on the court the last side from
Elena Kagan the left justice
they had trial experience was Thurgood
Marshall I don't know if I'm correct but
if you could check me out and I just
don't understand why nine of the best
and the brightest can't agree on a five
page document okay let me let me let me
just everything can thank you for your
question and just if I may explain a
somewhat cryptic statement that I Kermit
Roosevelt Kermit Roosevelt was a CIA
official in the United States who helped
initiate a coup d'etat in Iran in the
1950s which alleged well it has led to a
lot of bitterness towards the United
States in in Iran I don't pretend to be
an expert but that's just that that's
the reference you know as for why the
Supreme Court justices can't agree here
I have a lot of sympathy for the
justices because you know this is a
question I often get about the Supreme
Court it's like why do they have to
disagree so much why can't they just be
judges not politics
why can't they just put put the politics
aside and just reach legal decisions
well if you look at the controversial
issues before the Supreme Court if you
look at affirmative action abortion
same-sex marriage all the all these
sorts of issues there are not a
political answers to these questions
these are questions that are as much
political as legal so you know you can't
expect people to put aside their
political views to answer their
questions because these questions
themselves are so bound up in politics
as much as law and this is why I you
know always say in presidential
elections that you know people should
understand that when they are voting in
a presidential election they are voting
for the future of the Supreme Court and
it will be very different if Donald
Trump is President or Hillary Clinton is
president especially because of how old
the justices are now you know by you
know a year into the next presidency
Ruth Bader Ginsburg Stephen Breyer and
Anthony Kennedy will all be in their 80s
now the 80s aren't as old as they once
were but the 80s are still their 80s and
we can certainly expect there will not
just be the Justice Scalia vacancy which
exists now but multiple vacancies over
the next four or eight years a reminder
follow us on twitter at book TV and you
can like us and join us on facebook at
Facebook
our guys doing us from Pratt West
Virginia go ahead please hi a few years
ago c-span featured a reporter named
Matt Taibbi who was speaking about his
book called the divide I'm wondering if
you've read that book mr. Toobin and I
was just I'm one of these people really
struggle with inequalities in our
justice system and since these percent
CNN is doing a lot of documentaries
these days is there any way you can
take a look at that book and see if you
can work with CNN to do some kind of a
documentary about the inequalities in
our court system especially for poor
people and people that are been already
you know argue I I didn't I've not read
that book by Matt Taibbi but I'm very
familiar with this working mostly rights
for Rolling Stone now and you know III
think you don't always have to have a
winning candidate to have an influence
in the United States you know Barry
Goldwater lost in 1964 a catastrophic
landslide to to Lyndon Johnson but if
you look at the Goldwater campaign you
see the roots of the reagan campaign you
see the roots of the the country's right
turn in in subsequent years if anyone's
interested in that subject in particular
the the the the books of Rick Pearlstein
really identify the the how in the loss
of 1964 the the future of the Republican
Party is really revealed I say that
because I think the caller's question
very much is related to the Bernie
Sanders campaign I mean the Bernie
Sanders campaign was a real phenomenon
of the 2016 campaign he got a lot of
votes he won a lot of states Hillary
Clinton's positions on the issues
changed and moved to the left
undoubtedly because of Bernie Sanders
starting with her position on the
trans-pacific partnership trade
agreement you know the the the
democratic party of 2016 is dramatically
more liberal than it was in 1992 when
Hillary Clinton's husband you know we
was very intentionally moving the party
to the right and I think the call is
concern about inequality is really
shared by a lot of people in in this
country and I think Bernie Sanders
campaign and the enormous success of it
really illustrates that
how or whether that will translate into
actual action if Hillary Clinton is
elected president I don't know I think
it's gonna be difficult because we live
in a very polarized moment as the
Democratic Party is more liberal the
Republican Party is more conservative
and seems likely will control the House
of Representatives if not the Senate as
well so how Hillary Clinton can maneuver
between her more leftward direction that
she has taken and a Congress that is
unlikely to approve much that's going to
be one of the challenges of her
presidency if she's elected president I
want to take you back 32 years from the
CBS News archives 1984 and get your
reaction
good evening from CBS News this is news
break nicaragua's president-elect
leftist Daniel Ortega has called for a
summit with President Reagan to ease
tensions the sandanista leader says US
pressure was behind Nicaragua's efforts
to obtain weapons from the Soviets 2,000
mourners attended a memorial service
today for baby Fay the infant who made
medical history when she received a
baboon heart transplant police have
identified skeletal remains near Seattle
as another victim of the Green River
serial killer bringing the number of
known victims to 28 and in Tampa Florida
Robert long has been charged with the
murder of nine young women in that state
now this Jeffrey Toobin your mother
that's my mother's Marlene Sanders yeah
you know my mother was one of the
pioneering television women on
television news she was at ABC for many
years she was at CBS when she was doing
those news breaks and alas she died last
summer in in July of 2015 but you know
it's so interesting to watch her on
television because she was so good at it
you know she she had a great voice she
had a terrific presence on television
she looked great I mean it was really it
was you know my television career you
know i-i've had a it's bizarre that I
I'm in I'm in the same business but I'm
you know I've never been an anchor and I
have no ambitions to be an anchor but
she was so good at reading from a
teleprompter and presenting the news it
takes someone who was in the business I
think did see good she was and she was a
great mom as well did she consider
herself to be a pioneer or was she just
looking for a job you bet she thought of
herself as a pioneer especially in
retrospect I mean you know when I was a
kid and she was just starting out she
was just looking for a job but you know
being a being the first woman to anchor
and it was newscast being the first
woman to be a vice president of a
network news operation all of that was
very important to her I mean
was a very serious and committed
feminist and she was concerned not just
about her own progress but the progress
of all women in in all fields and she
was very proud of the fact that she was
she was a pioneer and your dad was a
journalist as well my dad was as well my
dad was Bill Moyers producer in public
television for many years and he was
later director of news at wnet the
public television station in New York
unfortunately my dad died a long time
ago he died in 1984 and while I was
still in law school so unfortunately I
haven't been able to share my
professional career with him to say
nothing of what would be his
grandchildren who weren't who weren't
there yet but he was a wonderful
inspiration as well among other reasons
as a a man who supported feminism very
much and you wrote a piece of New Yorker
about your own career in the dichotomy
and you use that word in terms of being
a lawyer an author
somebody who's on CNN really bridging so
many different platforms I think of
myself as an itinerant content provider
that's sort of my job description yeah
let's go to Rick you answer my question
so we'll go to Rick joining us on the
phone from red feather Lakes is at
Colorado it is Colorado - Colorado okay
I have a kind of a general
constitutional question I'm not a
scholar and I'm not an expert but I have
read the Constitution a few times and as
I see it just as a citizen reading it
what strikes me is the first article the
longest article the most specific
article is about the legislative branch
and then there are two short articles
about the additional two branches that
would indicate to me just as kind of a
singing person that the legislative
branch was perceived by the by the
founders as the central branch of
government the most important and when I
see that the president currently has a
54 percent approval rating but the
government has a whatever it is a 70
percent disapproval rating it strikes me
that
that's not difficult to explain if you
can agree that the running of the
country is primarily the job of the
legislature they're the ones who can
fire the president they're the ones who
can make taxes make war what is your
thought about about sort of the
evolution of our of the three branches
of government where we have well if I if
I can just answer your question I mean
III think you pinpoint something that is
so important and and this is an
observation that you know I think he's
not made often enough and it's why it's
a really good idea for people to
actually pick up and read the
Constitution occasionally and and be to
me every time I read it my reaction is
very much like the callers which is
article one describing the legislative
powers is much longer than article two
and even longer again than article three
which describes the judiciary powers and
we now live in a system where since
Marbury vs. Madison in 1803 the courts
can invalidate anything the other two
branches do I think the real turning
point came in terms of the balance of
power between the executive branch and
the legislative branch came with the
nuclear bomb I mean I think in 1945 once
it became clear that the president could
essentially end the world with the push
of a button metaphorically the the power
in this country had to go in the
direction of the executive branch
because you know the fact that we lived
with the existential threat of
extinction for 40 years and still
technically do as well there are still
nuclear weapons pointed at us out there
in the world I think that led to a
tremendous shift of power from the
executive from the legislative branch to
the to the executive branch it's very
hard to move it in the other direction
it's also it's particularly hard to move
it and
other direction when Congress is so
dysfunctional when you have a filibuster
system in the Senate that requires 60
votes to get anything done very little
gets done so that the fact that you have
an executive who can actually get things
done in a legislature that either
chooses not to or can't is another
explanation for why power has shifted
that way a tweet from Pam saying would
you be interested in running a book on
Justice Ginsburg you know one of the
things I know from my involvement in the
publishing business is that there are a
lot of books in the works about Justice
Ginsburg even as we speak and there was
a wonderful book published called
notorious RBG that that sort of a
paperback original wonderful book Aaron
Carmen wrote it a friend of mine last
year I'm gonna leave RBG to other
authors because there are plenty of them
circling around around her at the moment
and another tweet saying Jeffrey Toobin
Zaman was a pioneer in TV the things you
learn on at book TV ads I'm delighted to
share that piece of information from
Cleveland Ohio Nevel is next thank you
for waiting go ahead with your question
or comment speaking of my mother a
native of Cleveland Ohio eventually and
I observe you on CNN as a legal mind on
CNN but my question has to do with the
importance of the legal background of
our congressmen I believe that more
congressmen lawyers than in any other
profession can you say whether you think
that having congressmen being of legal
background is in any way significant for
the way this country is run you know I I
don't really think it matters that much
you know throughout the history of the
Supreme Court
the law school that has sent most
justices to the Supreme Court you know
which one it is
none for for decades most of the Supreme
Court justices didn't go to law school
at all they it was only in the mid 20th
century that law school became a common
route to being a lawyer most law most
lawyers became lawyers by clerking with
an old lawyer the way an older lawyer
the way Abraham Lincoln did so you know
I don't think the fact that most many
members of Congress are lawyers has much
to do with the with the the problems and
the issues I think Congress really
reflects where the country is at this
point this is a deeply polarized country
and when you combine that with partisan
redistricting the fact that most House
seats have been crafted by state
legislatures to be overwhelmingly
democratic or overwhelmingly Republican
you see many more many fewer moderates
who are interested in in cooperating in
the house that to me is a much more
significant development in Congress than
the fact there are a lot of lawyers
there let me go through a couple of your
books let me go back to opening
arguments you say quote I spent most of
my frantic first weeks trying to pretend
that I was having less fun than I was
fencing with Ed Mises minions playing
chicken with the White House
battling Ollie north I was having the
time of my life I wasn't I was a kid I
mean I you know now I sound like you
know only only an old person can talk
about a you know I guess I was 29 years
old our 28 or 29 I was just you know
just out of my clerkship and it was
heady stuff it was cool it was great I
think actually one of the lessons though
that I learned in opening arguments and
I learned in the iran-contra experience
is that I went in to that process
thinking that you know we had a mandate
to sort of you know show what a how
terrible the Reagan administration was
and I learned from my colleagues and
just from from the world that those
sorts of ambitions are unhealthy for
prosecutors that to the extent
prosecutors have political goals and
ambitions that's a bad thing not a good
thing I think a narrow role for
prosecutors who should be concerned with
prosecuting actual crimes and only
prosecuting actual crimes not trying to
change political directions not trying
to affect elections that's what
prosecutors should do and you know one
of the reasons I wrote opening arguments
it was the story of my understanding
that my initial ambitions were flawed
and that it's better for prosecutors to
have a more limited conception of what
they should do and so therefore what's
the connection between Thurgood Marshall
the n-double-a-cp
and special prosecutors no is there one
I would say well I you wrote in the book
about how that really led to the
creation of the special prosecutors well
I got I I'm not sure I see it I see I
mean the Public Interest lawyers who are
filing lawsuits as the n-double-a-cp
Legal Defense Fund did to end
segregation in the United States that is
an explicitly partisan political agenda
just as you know Evan Wolfson and the
other lawyers who were trying to end the
bans on same-sex marriage in the United
States had an explicitly political
agenda that's perfectly appropriate our
system is designed for people to use the
legal system in that way it is not
designed in my opinion for prosecutors
who have the power of government behind
them not independent actors like Public
Interest lawyers but government lawyers
to try to use that power to affect
political change that's a bad idea from
the run of his life and you said this
earlier but in case our audience hasn't
been with us for three hours as to the
central fact in this case it is my view
that OJ Simpson murdered his ex-wife and
her friend on June 12 any rational
analysis of the events and the evidence
in question
to that conclusion that's what I think
and I have not been shy about that
conclusion over the past 22 years I mean
III think OJ Simpson killed killed those
two people and he got away with it and
that is a real stain on the court system
interestingly the FX series that was
based on my book did not take an
explicit position on the guilt or
innocence of OJ I mean they obvious they
laid out a lot of the evidence and I
think the evidence clearly points only
in one direction but I think Ryan Murphy
and the other filmmakers made a very
smart decision not to have an explicit
conclusion in the series they didn't
show a reenactment of OJ committing the
crimes it was much more about how the
legal process worked and how and and
explained how the acquittal came about
from too close to call if the recounts
had proceeded they might not have gone
Al Gore's way but the fact remains that
Gore did not do nearly everything he
could to secure his victory so the
nation can never know whether a more
determined effort might have succeeded
you went on to say that under all the
standards when the votes were counted
the result was the same Gore won the
margins of course were tiny but under
the scenarios from the most liberal to
the most conservative Gore emerged the
victor right this this this is from the
recount conducted by the media
consortium which was somewhat different
than the media recant then the recount
conducted by the Miami Herald which
which we heard about earlier in the
program it is true that the full state
recounts favored Gore under under all
those scenarios but I don't pretend and
and I've said this before I don't
pretend that we can know with certainty
who would have won the election if the
Supreme Court has a lot had allowed the
recount to proceed to continue but
that's just my point is that by by
ending the recount the Bush the the
Supreme Court guaranteed that we will
never know
and from American Harris despite the
rhetoric of the communicates the SLA was
not you say a vehicle for social or
political change it was a spectacle an
instrument for getting attention for its
own sake right you know one of the
things that that you know really struck
me is an important part of the SLA is
that you know there was Donald DeFries
general Field Marshal sink you who was
the nominal leader but the brains of the
operations such as it was came out of
the Indiana University theater
department and this time in the early
70s was a time of guerrilla theater and
performance art and basically people
making spectacles of themselves in for
political change and if you look at the
theatrical nature of how the SLA
operated whether it was kidnapping a
famous heiress or putting cyanide in
their bullets or putting Patty Hearst in
front of the cameras during a bank
robbery it was all designed to create a
public spectacle what the SLA had
absolutely no idea about was how to
foment actual political change they saw
themselves as the American counterpart
to the revolutionary movements around
the around the world the Tupamaros in
Uruguay the Red Brigades in Italy the
baader-meinhof game gang in in Germany
but even more than those groups this
these people were utterly clueless about
how to recruit anything more than the
tiny band that they started with in this
picture from La I believe East 54th
Street you can take a look at the
monitor what are we looking at yes that
is the may 17th 1974 Patty Hearst and
two of the SLA members went off shopping
and got into a and and had two got into
a shootout and and had to leave the
other six members of the SLA
were caught in this house that that's on
the screen now and this house was the
subject of what is still to this day the
biggest police shootout in American
history
five thousand rounds of ammunition there
you see video of of it the five thousand
rounds of ammunition went into that
house
three thousand rounds of ammunition came
out and all six of the SLA members who
were inside were killed
the LAPD thought that Patricia Hearst
was inside the house at the time of the
shootout and so she understood that her
life was in danger in a very direct way
which was one reason why over the next
year she went on the run with the S with
the remnants of the SLA because she saw
that this this is the fate that might
await her she was caught and we take it
for granted today but we said that
graphic on the bottom many many time
this is a whole new technology developed
well this is another example of how the
the Hearst case previews the modern
world can XT was the CBS affiliate in
Los Angeles it's now known as KCBS they
had a new technology which was the
ability to put a satellite on the top of
a satellite transmitter on the on the
roof of a truck and make a live breaking
news event available to their to to
their viewers before the invention of
the minicam the only way you could do a
live broadcast was to lay cable weeks in
advance like at a political convention
or a World Series games but there they
were able to take a minicam to this
shootout the other local affiliates in
Los Angeles said to K and X T we really
want your feed can we broadcast it as
well so they picked it up then
nationally it was picked up around the
country because the minicam had just
been invented and
that was the first live breaking news
event broadcast around the country which
now of course we take for granted that
we can go live anywhere at any time
let's go to Jeff in Woodbridge Virginia
with Jeffrey Toobin yeah I noticed
during the break that c-span had that
you one of the most influential people
that you had was Robert Caro I'm just
wondering do you know how he's doing and
he's very meticulous as you know as far
as his work and and what the progress is
on the last book III haven't seen him
probably in about a year but a year a
year ago he was he was plowing ahead and
you know one of the weird things in his
the the way he has done the book is that
if he's gonna put everything into this
last volume it's gonna be a pretty long
volume because he's got most of the
Johnson presidency still to go he's got
virtually all of Vietnam ahead of him
and then you have the four years that he
lived after he left the White House and
here is a Supreme Court fact that
involves Lyndon Johnson Lyndon Johnson
died on January 23rd 1973 which was the
day that roe v wade was decided so roe v
wade was not the lead story in the
newspaper the next day let me share this
email from Darren in Baltimore he has a
couple of questions but one did Jeffrey
meet or interview the late Oh Jay
attorney Johnnie Cochran if so what was
he like
you know I disagreed with Johnnie
Cochran about the OJ Simpson case I
[Music]
disapproved of some of the tactics he
used in the courtroom but I can say this
now that he is now that he has gone I
loved
Johnnie Cochran I just thought he was
one of the most delightful intelligent
appealing charismatic people I've ever
met in terms of like pure charisma the
three-peat
I would put in a category different from
everywhere else our Oprah Winfrey Bill
Clinton and Johnnie Cochran
the phrase lit up the room is something
that Johnny did wherever he went and yes
he defended bill he defended OJ Simpson
and yes in my opinion Oh Jay Simpson was
was guilty as hell but Johnnie also
defended a lot of people who were not
prominent and he did a lot of good in
the world especially when it came to the
story of race in Los Angeles so I think
it's a heartbreaking thing that Johnny
died so young and I was a big fan if it
does not fit it must acquit you must you
must occur it must you must acquit yeah
I mean you know he had a charisma and a
way with words that was undeniable and
that came through to the jury and and in
this case and every other I mean this
this was this was this was a good man
let's go to gym in Tacoma Washington mr.
Chouhan this is a pleasure I've been
reading you for going on 25 years with
starting with your first book and two
more books after that and a lot of your
New Yorker pieces
thank you I certainly really get the
Patty Hearst look I was living in the
Bay Area going to college at that time
so the memories are vivid to me and 20
years later I found myself living in
Brentwood right across from Nicole on
Bundy when the killings occurred and so
I watched the trial avidly
and within a couple of weeks I read a
piece of yours in The New Yorker saying
that the defense was going to target a
cop named Mark Fuhrman that's right and
sure enough that's how the you know the
case unfolded and when they came up with
those tapes I've got my water that just
kind of blows him out of the water
completely when the case was over I
thought if there's any one person you
could attribute the loss of this case to
it would be Mark Fuhrman how in the
world he's ever been rehabilitated a
felon he might you know at best
described as a racist perjuring ex-cop
it's now an officer shows up on
television I just don't understand how
people are gonna think that that trial
was wrongly decided are embracing this
clown who probably did more to sabotage
it than anybody well I think you make an
interesting point and I think it is
worth remembering where he is now a
prominent analyst it's Fox Fox News it
is a conservative news outlet he is a
figure who has become a prominent
defender of police against black lives
matter accusations he is a prominent you
know someone who is part of the backlash
against the movement that Johnnie
Cochran reflected so you know he has
become a conservative hero of sorts not
because he lied I think people sort of
gloss over that but because he is seen
as someone who was the adversary of the
people who were playing the race card
during the OJ Simpson case I think his
his political place in in American life
as reflected in his role at Fox is
what's worth remembering about Fuhrman
out in American eras you say rarely have
the benefits of wealth power and
renowned been as clear as they were in
the aftermath of Patricia's conviction
my question to you if you could have
asked her one question as you say in the
epilogue she did not cooperate with the
book but a lot of material that you
could go through what would you have
asked her well that you know IIIi don't
have the the the arrogance to think that
one question could turn you know you
could turn the tables on anything I
talked about one incident in particular
actually III would ask her to explain
one thing in particular because I think
it is emblematic of how much she did in
fact switch sides to join the SLA and
that was on May 16th 1974 you know they
had just robbed the bank in San
Francisco and they all moved to to Los
Angeles
nine of them they were going stir-crazy
in the little house and three of them
decided to go shopping Patricia and Bill
and Emily Harris bill Harris goes in to
Mel's Sporting Goods and genius that he
is decided to shoplift
the clerk was an aspiring police officer
and he knew that the crime of
shoplifting did not actually take place
until the person left the store so he
waited until bill left the store and
then he tackled him out on the street
Patricia Hearst is across the street in
a van by herself with the key in the
ignition what does she do does she walk
away does she drive away does she ask
for help no what does she do she sees
Bill Harris being tackled so she picks
up a machine gun and fires across the
street amazingly not hitting anyone but
trying to free bill she does that thinks
it over then gets another gun and shoots
up the street some more again
miraculously not hurting anyone but
successfully freeing bill from the
clutches of his pursuer and Bill and
Emily Harris get in the car and the
three of them head off so when people
say you know Oh Patricia was forced to
do everything Oh Patricia was coerced Oh
Patricia was a victim forever
think about the incident in Mel Sporting
Goods and I would want her to explain
how her behavior at Mel's shooting up
that Street in order to free her comrade
bill Harris how is that consistent with
someone who was not actually a member of
the SLA America was next from Las Vegas
hi mr. Tobin
back to Monica Lewinsky and President
Clinton President Clinton did not ask
Monica to lie in her deposition he asked
her to lie in a different position thank
you
well let it go with that don't forget to
tip your waitress ronald randall
washington go ahead please yes
Oh Jeffrey as I I'm Allah I take an
interest in psychology and psychiatry
and I recently read that there is a
syndrome now about people like Patty
Hearst and that might answer you your
your reason for why she was the way she
was during that supporting good example
that you gave you'd have my daughter
Stockholm Syndrome right yeah you're
talking about Stockholm Syndrome well
let me tell you something about
Stockholm Syndrome Stockholm Syndrome
the reason it's called Stockholm
Syndrome is that there was a robbery of
a bank in Stockholm and Stockholm Sweden
where it was in November of 1973 so it
was just a few months before Patricia
was kidnapped and it had not really
seeped into popular culture yet and
during her trial it was actually not
mentioned it's only subsequently as it's
become famous that that Stockholm
Syndrome has been associated with her
case the idea behind Stockholm Syndrome
is that people who are held captive can
come to identify with their captors and
support their captors even though they
are technically prisoners it's important
to remember about Stockholm Syndrome and
brainwashing that these are journalistic
terms they are not medical terms and I
try to stay away from that sort of
jargon in the book and concentrate
instead on the actual facts of what went
on at Patricia's trial there were three
psychiatrists testified for the
prosecution three psychiatrists who
testified for the defense they disagreed
I think with all due respect to
psychiatry it's an imperfect science and
I I think it is a more helpful way to
view the hearse case and what I try to
do in the
and American heiress is to view it
through the facts of the case rather
through them through what I regard
mostly as psychobabble January 29th 1979
this picture of Patty Hearst with the
t-shirt pardon me after she her sentence
was commuted by Jimmy Carter and you
make a point that Ronald Reagan played a
role in this with an eye on 1980 it's
it's very interesting you know by the
time of the pardon it was quite clear
that Ronald Reagan was likely to be
Jimmy Carter's opponent in the 1980
election the Reagan Ronald Reagan was a
friend of the Hearst family he had
appointed Kathryn Hearst Patricia's
mother to be on the Board of Regents of
the University of California she was
very conservative big supporter of
Governor Reagan's and the fact that
Reagan and John Wayne the very
conservative actor supported the pardon
gave Jimmy Cardin political cover to
issue the commutation that he did
because he knew that his main opponent
was not going to criticize him and
Carter who was a religious man and
someone who believes in the concept of
redemption was was interested in this
case and was sympathetic to Patricia and
but also Carter knew that by granting
the pardon the the commutation he was
not exposing himself to criticism from
Reagan because Reagan supported it as
well I ask you this not because it's our
network but in researching the justices
I know you traveled to West Lafayette
Indiana I did it was great no what did
you find and what did you learn well it
was you know let me just back you know
just sort of back up I'll tell you I'll
tell you when I started working on the
nine which was my first Supreme Court
book one of the things I was worried
about it's like how am I gonna get
enough information about what the
justices are like behind the scenes
because I knew I could talk to some of
them but not all of them and you know
the the richness of the story was going
to be about what went on behind the
scenes not not what went on in public
and I always remember something
that my editor David Remnick said to me
he says you'll be amazed at how much is
out there in plain view on any subject
but about the Supreme Court in
particular so I started with the this
book came out in in 2007 so you know I'm
talking about sort of the mid 2000s when
I was reporting it and I started using
the internet which was of course not as
ubiquitous as he as it is now and I saw
that the justices had appeared on c-span
with some regularity so I this was the
days though before c-span had put all
its archives on on the web because you
know just the web didn't work that way
in those days but I called and and your
colleagues had told me that if I went to
West Lafayette Indiana where the c-span
archives were I could look at the
justices appearance to my heart's
content now as your viewers might want
to ask well why West Lafayette Indiana
well your former your founder and leader
Brian lamb was a proud graduate of
Purdue University which is in West
Lafayette that's what led to the the
archives being there so I went to the
archives and I remember I don't know if
this is still the case but they had this
sort of cool automated system for
getting DVDs they had this sort of
machine that pulled them off the off the
like a kind of some sort of storage
system and I remember kind of it's still
there is that right but and and I got
DVDs that were incredibly useful because
you know the justices they're human
beings when they talk off the cuff they
sometimes say things that on reflection
is a little more candid that they might
expect in it we and it was really going
to Wesley F West Lafayette was a gold
mine now by the time I got to write the
oath c-span had put almost all its
archives online so I was denied the
great pleasure of going back to West
Lafayette and and but but I still use
these eastbound archives a lot you're
welcome anytime
let's go to Susan in Cambridge
Massachusetts with Jeff hi hi in
responding to the many viewers who have
called in saying well why is the Supreme
Court decisions why isn't it just what's
right and wrong and why are there we
split you've done an admirable job at
explaining being that politics is going
to be necessarily a part of this but I
think you've gone too far in that my law
professor from my mentor in law school
Robert cover told me many many years ago
that a lot of American law could be
explained by the principle the railroad
always wins you know for many years of
our existence but that's not the
interesting question and it doesn't make
it law what distinguishes law from
politics is that they have to give
reasons why the railroad wins once you
give reasons either you stand by those
reasons and later decisions and that
means occasionally the railroad doesn't
win or the Republicans have to vote
liberal or the Liberals have Democrats
have to vote with the Republicans or law
losses or legitimacy and I think that
what's wrong with wish me gore is that
most wrong is that the court said forget
what our reasoning is we don't care you
could never use this again this is just
we want to decide it well I you know if
I can if I can stop you there I mean I
think you you you pinpoint a lot of
important points in what you said I
don't want to overstate my view that
everything that the Supreme Court does
is just purely political remember that
about half of their decisions every year
or unanimous 2/3 are close to unanimous
I mean there is a lot of what they do
that is just being a legal technician
and and you are right to that the
obligation to write down the reasons for
what they do
does does suggest that they have to
maintain at least some ideological and
intellectual integrity in what they do
and you are right further
that Bush v Gore is such a disastrous
example of the Supreme Court inaction in
part because the Conservatives who were
in the majority betrayed their usual
principles equal protection should be
narrowly construed states should be
allowed to maintain their own procedures
for running elections and most
notoriously of all it has that sentence
in it which said this case is not a
precedent for further further citation
which you know again undermines the idea
that the the justices are acting in a
consistent way but if I can just sort of
go back to where I started from you know
the famous Robert Jackson quote they are
not final because they are infallible
they are infallible because they are
final that was the last word and that's
what we got but they're certainly not
immune from criticism for it I've given
them plenty this is a fun question for
you who would be your Mount Rushmore of
Supreme Court justices in Tobin Perry
says to conservatives to liberals okay
certainly I would put Robert Jackson
among the Conservatives Robert Jackson
is you know I was the the period he was
on the court in the 40s and 50s it
wasn't as politically polarized as today
but I would say he was probably on the
more conservative side I am a great
Robert Jackson fan because he was I am
certain to say the the best writer ever
to appear ever to serve on the Supreme
Court and if someone wants to see a
great piece of American writing they
should look up his opinion in Garnett
versus West Virginia School Board which
is about whether children can be
required to salute the flag it is a
brilliant brilliant piece of writing so
he's one conservative the another
conservative I think John Marshall
Harlan the the the the younger who
served on the court in the 1950s an
Eisenhower appointee there's an
old-fashioned kind of East East Coast
moderate Republican another conservative
who I admired a great
deal in terms of the the Liberals I you
know leaving leaving off the justices
who are on the court now I mean you'd
have to pick William Brennan because you
know he was the architect of so many of
the Liberals decisions of the sixties
and I think the other you'd have to take
is Earl Warren because even though he
was not a great legal scholar he was
someone who had tremendous political
sense and understood that in the middle
of the Cold War when we were trying to
create an alternative model to the
Soviet Union we could not have
segregation in this country anymore so
whether it was brown v board of
education which he wrote or all the
subsequent integration cases I think
Warren's
political sense as much as his legal
made him an epic figure and an earlier
point this is from Tom Hines sending us
an email he is in Las Vegas saying under
the Constitution could the Senate refuse
to consent any Supreme Court nominee by
a potential eight years of President
Hillary Clinton absolutely absolutely
there is the Constitution does not
impose any sort of time limit on the
requirement the the only thing the
Constitution says is that the power to a
point is with the president with the
advice and consent of the Senate
but it does not set a time limit it does
not say that the the Senate has to
consent they they can keep voting down
her opponents they cannot hold hearings
on our opponents I mean this is again
one of the many areas where law leads
yields to politics and the only remedy
for this sort of recalcitrant on the
part of senators comes on election day
where voters can say if you're not going
to consider Supreme Court appointments
I'm going to vote you out of office but
that's the only remedy there's no you
President Obama or if there is a
President Clinton can't go to court and
force the Senate to act this is a
political act
which will be resolved by political
means Bruce Wilmington Delaware our next
caller with Jeffrey Toobin yes mister to
them and I have a couple of questions
about presidential pardons now the
Constitution gives the president
virtually unlimited power to grant
pardons except in the case of
impeachment impeachment cases now there
have been some preemptory group for
preemptory pardons probably the most
famous of course is his Ford's pardoning
of Nixon correct
before he had actually been indicted or
committed any crime and then we have
another example of a sort of a group
pardon of the draft dodgers by carter
correct what new questions what prevents
the president from pardoning illegal
aliens if he wants to pardon one if he
wants to pardoned 5,000,000 one would
seem to think he had the authority to do
this according to Constitution uh you
know I think you're probably right
although I'd have to think that through
he could certainly pardon them from any
criminal prosecution I'm not sure he
could pardon them from deportation the
the the I'm not sure if the pardon power
extends to the power his control over
immigration one of the issues in the
Supreme Court case that where the court
deadlocked four to four at the end of
last term was the president saying I can
set my enforcement priorities I don't
it's quite clear I think everyone
acknowledges that the federal government
doesn't have the resources to deport all
eleven people million people who are in
this country illegally so the president
is saying I can establish priorities
that give some people the security that
I will not deport them that position was
not vindicated in the Fifth Circuit and
the Supreme Court Kollek divided four to
four
of the Fifth Circuit is the law is the
law at least of that circuit you know
could the president pardon all five
million I mean yeah he could certainly
pardon as many as he wants of actual
crimes I am less certain whether he
could pardon
the pardon power extended to the issue
of deportation I mean just just so we're
clear he's no one's suggesting he's
gonna do that but it's an interesting
question of whether he could or not we
only have about 15 we may go another
three hours I'm ready man but let me let
me go back to one of the points about
American heiress because despite all the
discontent the civil rights movement the
assassinations of Robert F Kennedy and
Martin Luther King and President Kennedy
you make the point that the 60s emerged
as the sense of the possibility that
blacks and whites could live in harmony
all of that dashed in the 1970s in part
because of Vietnam and the impeach of
the resignation of Richard Nixon yeah
this was one of the real revelations to
me in in working on American heiress
sort of the the distinction between the
60s and 70s in terms of sort of how
American society was as a whole you know
I sort of thought that the 60s was the
time of tumult and things sort of
chilled out in the 70s now it is
certainly true that there was terrible
tunnel in in the 60s there were
assassinations there were riots after
Martin Luther King's assassination there
were the Watts Riots I mean the Detroit
I mean I did the LA riot
you know the Watts Riots in in 1965 but
it is true too that in the 60s there was
this tremendous sense that the reason
people were so agitated is that they
expected better of America and they
wanted and believed America could be a
better place what happened in the 70s
was this real souring that that you know
you had the Summer of Love in 1967 in
San Francisco you had the Free Speech
Movement in in 1965 in Berkeley both of
which were characterized by a
significant degree of idealism by the
70s it had all curdled
and when Richard Nixon ended the draft
in the early 70s that really took out a
large part of the middle-class kids from
the the counterculture in protests and
they sort of realized that they were no
longer at risk and went about their
lives and the people who remained were
the really hardcore and they were angry
and they were violent and I and I keep
coming back to this statistic that to me
is just so astonishing which is in the
early and mid 1970s there were a
thousand political bombings a year in
the United States try to imagine what it
would be like to live in a country with
a thousand bombings a year with our
current media culture I mean this was an
angry depressed place the economy was
also in lousy shape you had the economy
you had the energy crisis you had
Watergate destroying faith in in in
political institutions it was just a
dark time and that the the Hearst
kidnapping was both a reflection and a
symptom of just how bad things were in
America and one quick question about the
Hearst family do you have a sense of
what they were worth at its peak and
what they're worth today well you know
what what's interesting is that William
Randolph Hearst the the patriarch who
died before Patricia was born knew that
his four sons were basically drunken
they're due else and he did not want his
sons to control the business so he set
up a trust said so that Outsiders would
always control nine of the 13 seats on
on the Hertz truck on the Hearst trust
so the the Hearst family have a lot they
had a lot of assets they you know they
had interests in in these trusts but
they didn't have a lot of access to cash
or control of the trust and in fact you
know Randy Hearst had to come up with
two million dollars and it was very
difficult for him even though you know
he had access you know he fear
radically had access to to more than
that but he didn't really now in terms
of today there's one key fact about the
Hearst Corporation it's still privately
held so we never know exactly how much
money the the Hearst have but in the
late 1970s the professional managers of
the Hearst Corporation made a decision
to invest in 20% of something called the
entertainment and sports programming
Network no the initials ESPN ESPN the
Hearst Corporation still owns 20% of
ESPN and that has been an incredible
cash cow so even though the Hearst are
still sort of a newspaper company and
sort of a magazine company both of
businesses that have not thrived in
recent decades the fact that they own a
big piece of ESPN has meant that the
company is still flourishing from
strawberry Plains Tennessee dennis is
next go ahead please hi I'm a big
admirer sir and it's an honor to talk to
you thank you I had three quick
questions and then I'll hang up and
listen if Secretary Clinton is elected
do you think she'd submit Merrick
garland as the nominee I'll pick someone
else then this will take one time that's
that's a really interesting question and
the short answer is I don't know but let
me tell you a little about the political
calculations that I think are involved
let's assume as I think correctly that
the garland nomination will expire at
the end and without action from the
Senate come January 20th of next year
Hillary Clinton can say to Mitch
McConnell look you of a choice you can
give me a quick vote on Merrick garland
and get this 63 year old moderate
confirmed or I will nominate a 45 year
old liberal and we can fight that one
out
now Hillary Clinton will face a lot of
pressure from here more liberal
supporters not to nominate Garland but
she has a problem too because if she
it's a real liberal the first six months
of her tenure are swept up in this one
issue and she can't get immigration
through reform through the Senate she
can't get infrastructure spending
through the Senate so she will have an
interest in trying to get at least this
first vacancy off the table so I
actually think there is a reasonably
good possibility she will renew my
nightmare Carlin in the hope and
expectation and perhaps with an actual
deal with the Senate that the
Republicans will figure let's take this
sixty three-year-old moderate as opposed
to someone who might serve longer Dennis
your follow-up question did we lose
Dennis you still there you must have yes
go ahead go ahead okay do you believe in
term limits for Supreme Court justices
absolutely I think it would be a big
improvement term limits and or mandatory
retirement and I I say that with full
confidence that it will absolutely never
happen because amending the Constitution
is very difficult and there's just no
constituency for it but I think the
situation is really out of whack
we don't believe in 30-year tenures for
presidents we shouldn't have it for
Supreme Court justices it places the age
of the justices so much in as a factor
Stephen Breyer gets asked this question
and he says something interesting which
I also agree with he says I don't have a
problem with term limits or mandatory
retirement but you have to set up a
system where being a Supreme Court
justice is your last job you don't want
Supreme Court justices angling for
something else then I think that that's
a good point
I think term limits are a good idea it
ain't gonna happen we welcome our
listeners on c-span radio again follow
us on twitter at book TV the first
Sunday of every month in-depth with
authors this month Jeffrey Toobin who
has written seven books and Counting a
lot of tweets having fun with the Mount
Rushmore questions so this is from a
viewer in Philadelphia would you include
John Marshall
on Mount Rushmore I goodness I certainly
would I guess I didn't include him
because a I forgot and B I don't know if
you you asked me for two liberals and
two conservatives I don't know where you
would count John Marshall in that
pantheon is he a liberal is conservative
in the the world was so different in in
the early 19th century you know the the
man who created judicial review in
Marbury vs. Madison who helped define
the powers of the federal government in
Macabre McCulloch V Maryland I it's just
hard for me to place him in our current
political divisions we got a call from
San Francisco you've on your next hi
Jeffrey thank you for all your good work
with giant and joy thank you one time I
was unhappy was your article about one
of my favorite people Martha Stewart
when I thought you were kind of harsh is
there anything you can say now to make
me less unhappy well look you know what
did you say about my wife I said she was
guilty as hell of lying about her
insider trading situation you know the
the crazy thing about Martha Stewart's
whole scenario was that if from day one
she had simply said you know I made a
mistake I you know was thinking about a
lot of different things things I sold my
stock after hearing this news from my
friend this whole saga would have been
just a minor footnote you know Martha
Stewart is an extraordinary
entrepreneurs
she created this not just a business but
an industry and she's just an enormous
ly talented and and forceful person
unfortunately that forceful personality
led her didn't it to deny the completely
obvious fact that she had engaged in
insider trading in this scenario and she
wound up getting in so much more trouble
than she should have if she had just
said yeah I did it let me pay a fine
when none of us would even remember
here today but frankly out of arrogance
she she stuck with this ridiculous story
and and wound up in worse trouble but
that doesn't diminish the fact that
Martha Stewart is an enormous force of
nature and really one of the great
entrepreneurs of this era let's talk
about the arc of your career graduated
from Harvard Law School you were an
intern at New Republic Euclid oh I was
actually is never an intern I I feel i
freelance there yeah you clerked for US
Court of Appeals judge I did J Edward
Lombard and Eisenhower appointee you
worked for independent counsel at
Lawrence Walsh I did you started out as
a staff writer for The New Yorker worked
at ABC for a number of years and now at
CNN oh and you left out a very important
part I was an assistant US attorney in
Brooklyn which was a very happy and
proud part of my career which taught you
what about the law oh so much that that
it's just all about people and how they
react and and that you you know you can
read all the appellate decisions you
want but until you look jurors in the
eye and try to persuade them that
something happened or didn't happen you
don't really understand how the law
works and and what I loved about being a
trial lawyer and I had 11 trials in
three years which I felt so lucky to
have that you got to speak in English
now they don't want to hear more overs
and wherefores I mean they that you have
to speak to jurors in normal English to
them not at them to them not at them and
not and it's it's just a great education
in in real life and also just I mean III
really appreciated the spectacle of like
what goes on in an American courtroom
and this is why I think I was really
much more destined for journalism than I
was for law because what I really liked
about being an assistant US attorney was
something a lot of my colleagues like to
avoid which was arraignment duty an
arraignment Duty was when you got people
when they were first arrested and you
learned you know who they were and
like where they came from and what what
their backgrounds were when they you
know they're trying to get out on bail
so they would sort of tell you their
story and it was just so amazing I mean
the people who would swallow condoms
full of cocaine or heroin and try to
smuggle it into Kennedy Airport which
was far too part of our jurisdiction you
know the the people who got her arrested
for food stamp fraud the the people you
know the frauds in various communities
Ponzi schemes I just loved the spectacle
of it all but some of many of my
colleagues were like you know I'm gonna
do justice and I want to like get the
bad guys and I you know I wanted to get
the bad guys fine but I like the sort of
scene a lot it sound like Perry Mason
well I wasn't like Perry Mason because I
wasn't someone who was like I like who
wanted to win I mean obviously I wanted
to win but Perry Mason was all about
like the last-second victory in a
courtroom and I was like check this out
this is all crazy I love this and that
that's a different attitude than a lot
of other prosecutors Ivan from Ulis
Texas go ahead please calling about I
love America man and this is this is a
1:1 flag country and I see other flags
flying in America it's not right and the
border I'm on the Texas I'm I'm for the
border but I'm for the people coming in
but make them legal or they'll pay their
taxes and stuff because they're taken
from our health care they're sending
money back through Walmart to Mexico it
makes our dollar weaker and it's okay
long as you're illegal American and
speak America this is one country and
god bless all of us we've got to stand
up we lost our morals and when a
policeman Chris is you supposed to stay
in there not run off and fight the man
and that's what we have so many problems
and one guy an urban texas brings a
little clock to school and they follows
a bomb now they're gonna try to suit
early Urmi can't afford to be sued they
can barely afford their place apartments
Ivan thanks for the call you can hear in
his voice the issues in this campaign
absolutely and
and you know III think we are going to
spend a long time in this country
thinking about how Donald Trump became a
major party nominee I mean remember it
is worth noting that the only president
elected in modern American history who
was not an elected official was Dwight
Eisenhower who did did a little thing
called running the world war two in
Europe so I mean you know he was not a
public official but he sure was a public
you know a public servant you know how
we got to someone like Donald Trump with
no record at all of public service to be
a major party nominee is a really
interesting complex story that I don't
pretend to understand but I think this
callers unhappiness about immigration
not just as immigration per se as a
problem in and of itself but kind of as
a symbol as a metaphor for disorder in
the whole country and for the loss of
what America used to be you know I don't
think you can understate the importance
of Donald Trump's slogan you know make
America great again like to go back to a
time never specified exactly when
America was better than it is now a
different comma more orderly place
that's a real concern of a lot of people
and I don't think it's enough people to
get him elected president but it's a lot
of people and their concerns have to be
heard - final question why do you enjoy
writing oh why do I enjoy write because
I like telling stories I mean I like
telling people I know I recognize that
people have a lot on their plates in
their lives that they you know they're
distracted they've got their phones they
and if I can tell them a story that gets
them to sit down and read for an hour
for several nights in a row and say this
is unbelievable this is amazing
the way I do when I'm a reader when I
write what I want to read and I love to
read and I love
a good story especially a nonfiction
story and you know I I view it as a
challenge but also a tremendous
privilege to be paid to tell great
stories that are also true I don't have
the imagination to make them up but I'm
pretty good at like finding the things
that actually did happen your first book
back in 1992 opening arguments the young
lawyers first case US v Oliver North and
then the run of his life the People v OJ
Simpson in 1996 a vast conspiracy the
real story of the sex scandal that
nearly brought down the president it
came out in October of 2000 too close to
call 36 day battle to decide the 2000
election which came out in 2001 the nine
inside the secret world of the Supreme
Court from 2007 the oath the Obama White
House and the Supreme Court from 2012
and your latest book American heiress
the Wilde saga of the kidnapping crimes
and trial of Patty Hearst Jeffrey Toobin
thank you for spending 3 hours here on
c-span to's book TV what a tree thank
you and thank you to all those terrific
callers and emailers come back anytime
thank you very much